it's been a wild year and uh this is our
second to last timcast IRL of the year
we've got some big stories Ashley
stclair breaking a big story that there
are illegal immigrants who are flying on
airlines without IDs at all and being
given premi economy but it's not just
Ashley there have been many journalists
many commentators who have bumped into
this interestingly because of Turning
Point USA's amfest of these individuals
were flying out of the Phoenix Airport
and they could see that these airlines
are transporting illegal immigrants from
border states all over the country they
have packets they have information many
of them didn't speak English and many of
them don't even know where they're going
the concern now we're hearing is coming
from Pilots of these Airlines who don't
know who they're flying there's no
security screening they don't know where
these people are coming from there's no
medical screenings and so of course
naturally people are quite upset but
it's even affecting big cities like
Chicago where we're actually seeing
Democrat voters are standing up and they
are challenging the mayor they are
criticizing Joe Biden we even have an
olderman in Chicago a Democrat saying
that these policies are causing them
great problems so we do want to talk
about all of that but more importantly I
think it's a good opportunity to talk
about a lot of issues because we have an
awesome guest Marian Williamson will be
joining us and we'll talk about her
policies her plans the polling and I
think it'll be fairly interesting
considering she's actually polling quite
well among Democrats but for some reason
I think everybody gets it the media and
the Democratic establishment are n too
happy before we get into that my friends
head over to the best song ever.com and
buy the song click download your for
your price it is 69 and uh it's looking
pretty good A lot of people have
purchased the song this is uh the final
the final call to action uh the final
call to action is today at midnight the
tracking officially ends and we will see
one week from then where we end up on
the Billboard charts and we're hoping
that we did fairly well the song
actually did better than all of our
other songs that we've put out so we're
really excited for that apparently we
were trending in Toronto and Hong Kong
surprising and a special shout out to
the Daily wire crew Jeremy boring
Michael nolles for the original song the
lyrics which we used and for helping
promote as well it's looking really
really uh really great so let me just
say to each and every one of you who
want to help us smash through the gates
of these institutions and the machines
that seek to keep us from it download
this song for 69 it's the last
opportunity and we really do appreciate
all of your support it's looking pretty
good but uh I got to say we are finding
out just now in the 11th Hour they're
saying that something's wrong with the
tracking and the online streams sorry
but we don't know if we're going to be
able to count these and we knew this was
going to happen which is why we heavily
prioritized sales instead of saying go
watch the Youtube video like we did in
the previous uh releases because they
keep trying to play this game with us it
is what it is if everybody who's
listening right now downloaded the song
We would shatter our way into the
Billboard charts so uh with your support
we can make that happen also head over
to
timcast.net show coming up it should be
a lot of fun so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends as I already mentioned
joining us tonight is the lovely Maryann
Williamson hi thank you for having me
thank you for coming uh do you want to
introduce yourself I'm Maryann
Williamson and I'm running for the
Democratic nomination for the
presidency and
um yeah right on right on is there
anything else I mean I know I know
you're an author is there anything else
in in your career that you'd like to
I've had a 40-year career I've written
15 books
on inspirational spiritual subjects I
write and talk about the universal
spiritual themes at the heart of all the
great spiritual uh religious Traditions
I wrote a couple of books that are about
politics uh I've been a nonprofit
activist I founded nonprofit
organizations uh one that was an AIDS
organization that has served 16 million
meals uh to homebound people it began as
a an organization that would serve meals
to homebound people with AIDS and it as
it has continued through the years it
it's to all homebound people dealing
with critical illness because
fortunately there's less of the AIDS
related um situation in Los Angeles
today although it still exists obviously
um and I've founded co-founded peace uh
organizations I was once a non a
non-denominational Minister wow uh at a
a non-denominational church in uh Warren
Michigan so I've done a lot of things
and this is my second time running for
president right on and you we actually
have one of the recent polls showing you
at 133% among Democrats so it's actually
you're doing fairly well well I I'm
sorry oh no I was going to say so uh
we'll we'll we'll get into all of that
thank but I'm really excited to have you
here it's a it's an honor and a
privilege thank you so much for coming
thank you very much Phil abanti is
hanging out hello everybody my name is
philon a lead singer of uh heavy metal
band All That Remains uh very filled
musician anti-communist
counterrevolutionary we're here with Ian
yeah the guy I'm GNA make some I want to
I want to bring some scientific realism
to these crystals in front of me cuz
people make made fun of me in the past
crystals actually do vibrate you know
there's something called sympathetic
vibration where harmonic resonance can
cause one Crystal to start vibrating and
then other crystals across the room will
start vibrating and your bones have are
made of crystal called hydroxy appetite
in conjunction with other materials so
we're vibing this is why whenever
Allison and I go out we buy Ian rocks oh
and that's also why I got to chill keep
your tone cool because a lot of
communication is in the tone so let's
have fun thank you for buying those
rocks for me absolutely has a ton we B
the vibrating rocks I think what you
said relates to what we were talking
about with Twitter before that a lot of
communication is in the tone yeah and
with text it's lost the text is just
throwing a piece of paper at someone
basically yeah I mean I've had uh
somebody once said to me something about
something I I didn't like your tone or
something I said it's a
text there is no tone yeah yeah well
let's get into it we got searge pressing
the buttons yeah I'm hanging out uh
let's just start the show we're going to
start with this story from Ashley St
Clair because you know I'll be
completely honest I think this is we
have we have a great opportunity to talk
about uh much much larger issues as
we're we're ending out the year uh
tomorrow we'll have James O'Keefe and it
will be our last show of the year so
we're really excited but uh this is
still a very interesting story coming
from Ashley Sinclair which can kick off
an immigration discussion Ashley
Sinclair tweets I am in possession of
legitimate major airline boarding passes
for migrants that quite literally have
the name printed as no name given
incredibly incredibly difficult to post
these without putting the Insiders at
risk working on it this will continue to
unfold over the coming weeks but I
confirm these are legate boarding passes
I am at a loss for words for what I am
verifying thank you to everybody
reaching out Ashley stclair also tweets
receiving all of these tips I was able
to call many sources directly here on X
a pilot who wanted to remain anous
anonymous was able to create a burner
account join our space and use the
built-in voice change feature to stay
safe she then celebrates a the best
platform so far but the big news that
we've been seeing over the uh past
couple of days is record-breaking
illegal immigration flowing into Eagle
Pass we're seeing now over 10,000 per
day they're estimating around 270 or so
thousand individuals coming in just this
month and it's resulting in even
Democrats in cities like Chicago where
we're getting uh a lot of anger let me
see if I have this one uh not that one
where where's the the story at do we
have the uh well we have this one from
the Daily Mail Furious Chicago resident
rips into mayor Brandon Johnson for
throwing open the door to thousands of
migrants and letting down black
communities I think this is obviously a
major issue and some of the latest polls
on Donald Trump show that he is uh uh
Rising significantly especially on among
young people and it's because the
economy and immigration are huge issues
for people but uh let's just we can just
kick off the conversation with you
Marian and I'm curious what your
thoughts are on all of this I think that
in this as in so many areas we have to
treat root causes we have to ask we have
to ask why are people working going
through sometimes the most hideous
Journeys like through the Darian Gap the
Darian Gap in Mexico is one of the most
inhospitable areas in the world so what
would make someone walk across the Daran
Gap with two small children well
obviously desperation so what what is
the despair there are two main
categories one has to do with economic
destabilization in these countries uh
which has caused all this economic
desperation and the other is the
horrible violence that is perpetrated by
the drug cartels now I think that we
need to look in the mirror because if we
look at all of this economic despair a
lot of it was contributed to mly by US
foreign policy over the last few decades
one of the things that we have to do for
instance we need to end the sanctions on
Cuba we have to end the sanctions on
Venezuela I think a lot of people have
no idea what violence this does to the
lives of ordinary people we say to
ourselves well we're going to have a
sanction on this country and it's a
sanction against the bad guys who are
the leaders and then the story went that
uh the ordinary citizen in that country
would realize that that this is what was
causing it and they'd rise up against
the leader well it doesn't work that way
first of all the leader has
cryptocurrency the leader has bank
accounts in Switzerland the leader has
castles in Monte Carlo we saw this with
the sanctions on the Russian oligarchs
at the beginning of the Ukraine war
they're like whatever right so how
ironic that in countries like Cuba and
Venezuela our San are leading to a lot
of the despair that is then making
people come here we give something like
200 million in general in humanitarian
Aid to um Latin American countries I
think if we really look honestly at what
we have done to many of these countries
over the last few decades we would see a
lot more uh of a reason and a
justification for us seeking to
stabilize helping stabilize some of
these economies I also think that we
should end America's War on Drugs
because our war on drug drugs actually
contributes it it helps the drug cartels
because it creates all that black market
so I think that we can talk all day long
I was in Eagle Path several weeks ago I
saw the concertina wire I saw the buoys
that a federal judge has now told Greg
Abbott that he cannot use I saw where
1500 people drowned in the um Rio Grand
River um and I heard officials down in
in eath say to me we feel oppressed by
the state government and we feel
neglected by the federal government
because those people who are down there
know how to handle this they know how to
do the processing they know what is
needed and they're not listened to so
this is interesting we have uh this
story I want to I just want to pull this
up this is from ABC appeals court orders
Texas to remove floating buoys from Rio
Grand that was earlier in uh uh the
month but we also do have this story
from the post millennial federal judge
forbids Biden Administration from
removing Texas's border barriers so I
think they the the the buoys over the
water I think had to come out because of
international waterways restrictions but
we started to see with the uh the Razer
wire uh federal agents were lifting it
up and allowing people to enter and now
I believe that's being barred and Texas
has just passed a state law Banning
illegal entry into the state but the
state Greg Abbott is overriding federal
jurisdiction he does not have once again
this is why they're saying oppressed by
the state government um and neglected by
the US government it Greg Abbott is
taking on Authority that Governors do
not have these are to be these are laws
that are be to be passed by Congress not
by state Governors well what what
happens when you have 10,000 people per
day entering your state in your city
once again there's nothing you can do on
the level of symptom that's going to
fundamentally fix this this is why we
must address the underlying causes we
can talk about whether or not people are
detained we can talk about whether or
not people are deported but until we
actually address the root cause of the
problem this is going to remain with us
I agree but we can't ignore 10,000
people per day I mean if uh if we use
analogy if you you say symptom I'd
imagine someone gets shot we do need to
stop shootings but you still have to
tend to the wound and also the people
that are coming over they're they're not
really predominantly from South America
they're coming from all over the world
so I understand your point about
addressing the the problems in in you
know in South America or addressing the
some of the things like sanctions and
stuff I understand that but doesn't it
like doesn't that not you know cover the
problem if most of the people are coming
from other places like you know Africa
and Asia I think we also though need to
look at the overall picture of
immigration in this country because that
we can have an argument at numbers and
it's a legitimate argument but I think
we also need to stand back and look at
the overall picture which is
statistically an immigrant to this
country from anywhere if they are given
for one year the help that is necessary
to integrate Etc within a year they are
self-sufficient and if you look at the
big picture of immigration in the United
States The Immigrant population is a
contributor to the US economy and not a
suck on the US economy you know 150
years ago it was don't let in the Jews
don't let in the Polish don't let in the
Irish and there's a lot of that same
kind of racism that is going on today so
we have to ask ourselves it's one thing
to have a conversation about the numbers
and the overwhelm but it is to me uh uh
now leaned over into a a mean-spirited
attitude towards immigrants which is not
in keeping uh with the better angels of
our nature where did your
great-grandparents come from I mean all
four of my grandparents came here
seeking to escape oppression what about
yours neither of you none of you are
descended from from uh enslaved people
or from indigenous people are you I'm
part Korean well but not by the United
States they not slave by the United
States but my family was uh persecuted
when during during World War II with
Japanese internment because they didn't
care for the difference between
different types of Asian people so my
family was forced to flee and hide and
um my uh my mom side of the family which
was mixed race had to pretend like they
weren't actually related because it was
illegal at the time because of misation
laws and so the stories I grew up
hearing was uh my family fled 12
different states once found out that it
was a a mixed race family you know pre
1967 and would be Spit On by people for
being what they would call Japs despite
the fact that I am part Japanese but
mostly Korean so uh that is a component
and not to say that we're descendant
from American slave or anything like
that but my point is they so your family
found they found safety and Asylum and a
better life in the United States right
oh yeah absolutely so isn't there a
moral responsibility that those of us
who are descended from people like your
parents like my grandparents who found
that we don't have a moral
responsibility to make sure that others
experience that blessing as well because
there's a whole lot of people in the
world like that if we have a moral
responsibility to some wouldn't that say
mean we have a moral responsibility to
the to the world and then that's a moral
responsibility to everybody on Earth no
not everybody's trying to come here
would even want to come here I imagine
there's a lot of people that want to
that but I I I I think the answer is yes
legal immigration I'm sorry oh sorry I
was going to say I was going to agree I
believe the answer is yes however it has
to be legal right we we right now what
you know with with I think your view on
we must treat the symptoms there's a lot
of symptoms and I can respect absolutely
I question when we give money to these
South American and Central American
countries and their oligarchs and their
autocrats steal the money and it doesn't
help the people at all and exacerbates
violence the drug or all that absolutely
I want to treat that but then there is
another issue the American citizens of
Eagle Pass are suffering and I don't
believe it would be appropriate to just
say we will provide no reprieve for you
in the immediate because we're dealing
with larger issues
internationally say I was just in Eagle
Pass go down to Eagle P because I think
you might be surprised by the stories
that you hear from the people there you
know I grew up in Texas I grew up in
Houston people had been walking back and
forth Mexico and Texas literally for
centuries yeah literally for centuries
and the people in the eagle P that I
spoke to absolutely know how these
processing centers could work how the
medical could work it it could be set up
very differently than it is and the
people in Eagle Pass are the ones who
would know what to do but what about for
instance the people in Chicago the black
community specifically that has been an
uproar over the past several months you
said that plane came from
Phoenix so my question was which
Governor like we know for instance
remember when Greg Abbott sent all those
um immigrants on a bus to Massachusetts
is Massachusetts a sanctuary State
pardon is that is Massachusetts a
sanctuary it was a it was a to something
now when you read the followup stores
they're all doing well well they yeah
but they they were deported out of net
pardon they were removed from net the
the the the local residents revolted and
then put them all in buses and sent them
out yeah they they were there for like a
week and then they were like get beat it
get out of here they were complaining
they were they were having having uh
meetings Town meetings and stuff that we
don't have a place to put the put all
the people we don't you know we're we're
a uh a vacation town and blah blah blah
they could have put him in Massachusetts
is a sanctuary is is a deao sanctuary
State according to wgbh.org so the
argument I suppose from the likes of
Texas is if the federal government is
going to remove border barriers allow
these people to enter under their
Federal jurisdiction why not send these
people to states that welcome them no I
understand but then you end up with
Chicago residents and so Chicago it's
it's devastating because that's I'm from
I bring that up only because I'm from
there I know this is affecting a bunch
of other cities my friends are saying
the police departments are done they're
shut down basically because they were
overrun in the past few days they've
announced they're removing the migrants
from from the police stations to try and
find other places but the scary thing
now is they're talking about building
camps to put these people in like with
like that's I think that's hor the
situation to be handed at the handled at
the border obviously but what I heard
and saw at legal at Eagle Pass was that
there are ways to handle it at the
border it's Congress that has uh there's
been a dereliction of Duty for years
because everybody says on the left and
the right we want them to be able to
legally immigrate I think people want to
legally IMR but the pro but the the
Congress has laws or there there are
plenty of laws to to that can moderate
the people coming over the border that
are coming at least people that are
coming over IL legally if if they would
enforce it but the Department of
Homeland Security is not enforcing the
the laws at the border if I understand
correctly mayorcas was just on the hill
recently and and if I understand
correctly provided ex exceedingly
unsatisfactory testimony about what
they're doing he was swearing up and
down that he was doing what his is what
he's supposed to do but the evidence is
that we continue to have record numbers
of people crossing the border and we
have had I mean this year is is the the
the highest record you know on or the
the record this month particularly
10,000 people per day millions and
millions of people are coming over the
border so what do you do when the
government when the the the executive
won't enforce the laws won't tell the
the the guy that runs the border
security to enforce the laws and then
when the guy's brought in in Congress
he's just like n man we're totally doing
it and then and everyone's like well I
guess he's doing it cuz and nothing gets
done and I didn't see that testimony and
I didn't I didn't read the book they
were talking about impeaching me orcus
wow you know right I if I remember
correctly I think if we zoom out and
take like a macro look regardless of
what an individual Community like
Chicago or Eagle Pass might be saying
you have uh Abbott in Texas at a state
level takes the view that this is a
serious problem that is not being
resolved by the federal government and
the federal government's view is that
for whatever reason it should be
encouraged and facilitated uh encouraged
in the sense that they were using heavy
machinery to lift up Texas's border
barriers were filing lawsuits to remove
the barriers and bring these people in
and then fund the transport of uh these
people on planes and buses into other
places so something is happening in
Texas where locally the governor says it
is politically expedient for me to end
all of this illegal immigration and then
something's happening federally where
the administration says we will not do
anything to stop it and this creates a
conflict where the state is putting up
razor wire suing the federal government
to stop them from impeding on their
borders and and then sending these
people out on their own buses to Chicago
to New York and then you have the
federal government trying to actually
bring more people in I mean I I see that
as an untenable situation I saw the
booys and I saw the the memoral that was
erected to the people who had drowned it
is absolutely morally unacceptable those
buoys people drown because of those
buoys well I mean if if the people
choose to enter a river and come here
with those risks once again for me that
goes back to the the trauma in someone's
life that would make them take a journey
like that on foot over a desert through
the Baran Darian Gap and for the United
States to look at in what ways have we
contributed to that despair if you look
at us foreign policy in Latin America
over the last few decades you do you see
how many ways we have not supported
democracy but we we talk I I but but I
American foreign policy has I mean you
guys were talking about the CIA and all
that stuff H all the things you were
saying about the CIA before we went on
you think that that those things were
not happening in Latin America I think
that most of our immigration is if I
understand correctly most of our
immigration problem is not coming from
Latin America that's honestly a lot of a
lot of people being reported are from
North Africa or uh I think a lot of it
is economic destabilization through the
Federal Reserve System this this fiat
currency this we've just totally
annihilated the global economy by
printing 880 whatever to 8 trillion the
last few years so the symptom is it's
caused by the United States corrupt
economy over the last 50 years basically
the problem is when you look at a body
you can say like look we're causing a
problem in the body we're causing a
problem in the body something bad is
going to happen and then all of a sudden
it explodes and now we don't really have
a it we remember what was causing it but
now we need to treat the the
explosive uh result and the result is
300,000 people came if it takes one
person one year to adapt we have 300,000
new ones this month that's like almost
untenably unadaptable I don't I don't
know how how we can ease these people in
at that rate well you got to stoping I
mean look in Chicago i i find I find
this unacceptable in Chicago they are
building I I I hate to use the term
because I don't know what other term
there is but concentration camps I want
to draw distinction between obviously
World War II but they are building camps
and they are forcing these people into
them and it's causing a major crisis the
locals are Furious win in Chicago in the
winter in Chicago schools parents are
screaming that they started putting
these people in the gyms of of of of
middle schools the last thing I think
anyone will tolerate is hearing that the
federal government is loading people up
on buses and trains and it wasn't the
federal government that did that that
would have been the that would have been
a governor that would have been a state
what Illinois it's the mayor I believe
the mayor and the governor mayor is
receiving it that uh Johnson is the
mayor in Chicago but I see what you're
saying he's receiving them well the so
we do know for a fact that the Biden
Administration is facilitating the the
the the transport of migrants to various
locations how do we know that so there
was uh numerous reports notably one out
of Tennessee where Republicans actually
filmed the transport of migrants
underage uh uh uh migrant illegal
immigrants coming from the border were
loaded on the planes and flown into
Tennessee this particularly enraged I
think it was a senator from Tennessee
who then came out and said why in the
middle of the night are are planes being
charted by the federal government to
send these people into our state there
was actually whistleblower footage from
Westchester New York where a I believe
it was a police officer said if the
American people knew what the government
was doing paying for the trafficking of
these miners from out of the country
into New York be paying for the
trafficking be careful that you just
said paying for the trafficking yeah
trafficking is a specific word it
doesn't just apply to trans portation
well if you if you take an UND a minor
who's not from this country and
facilitate their transport from out of
the country into a part of the country
that's human trafficking so the coyotes
for instance are human traffickers they
so when you have someone in let's say
either it's uh uh Southeast Africa one
of the one of the big reports was a
large am large amount of people are are
paying for travel to Brazil and then
traveling from Brazil up to Central
America and through here they're paying
human traffickers to do that so the
traffickers facilitate a plan a path and
then the Biden
Administration working with the
traffickers facilitates the transport of
miners into uh uh deeper into the United
States from the border it might actually
be considered human smuggling
trafficking is specifically um for
commercial exploitation sexual slavery
or forced labor and I don't think the
the US government knowingly facilitates
that but they may be smuggling people
in well smuggling people in is
definitely part of the trafficking
problem there's no doubt about about
that I mean by definition they're
smuggling people and it can happen um in
inner inner country like internationally
or
inally there's there's one thing that I
want to talk about that when it comes to
immigration one of the things that that
people neglect to address is when you
have people like that are leaving I mean
yeah look I'm sorry just it it this is
this was a huge story a couple years ago
and this is NBC New York 2,000 uh uh
migrant children UND documented flown
into Westchester with bipartisan uh uh
uh politicians demanding answers from
the Biden Administration who won't tell
them what's going on and the smuggling
is distinct because uh it characterized
by the consent of the person being
smuggled so smuggling is probably a
better uh answer a better better word to
Define it and the question then becomes
why is it that if Democrat and
Republicans in the area are demanding to
know why the federal government is doing
this do we not have we we don't have
answers as to what's going on so you
know in in in the big picture I can say
this certainly the people who are
watching this show are Furious about
what's happening in in Texas and Florida
and and the southern border states
because they're they're bearing the
brunt of this so Greg Abbott Ronda
santis other Governors say why don't we
send these people to Sanctuary states
that have passed laws to protect them
because they seem capable and willing to
help them but now we see Illinois New
York and Pennsylvania Furious that it's
happening and and arguing that it's in
fact the fault of Greg Abbott that
they're facing this crisis when I mean
as you argue it's the federal government
who has the authority to do it and Greg
Abbott actually has no authority to stop
the waves of migrants that are coming in
well I would be very interested in
reading that but also when you talk
about the people who are so upset about
it in Texas I think a lot of the uh
issue of who's upset about it in Texas
has to do with particular political
orientation but does that matter yes it
does because there there are listen I'm
not arguing about whether or not too
many people are coming in but I do think
a lot of the hysteria even before even a
year ago before it was as as many
numbers as it is there was a lot of
anti-immigrant fervor that was based not
on a realistic appraisal of what
occurred what was occurring but rather
on on on on racism and anti-immigrant uh
uh perspective you know Ronald Reagan
gave six million immigrants amnesty when
I was growing up if you wanted to come
into this country uh if you wanted to be
a citizen all you had to do was walk
down to the to the registry office do
you think that that the United States is
a more racist country now than we were
say 20 years ago or 50 years ago oh
that's an interesting question no
because we're not we're not a monolith
but I do think you know so you can't say
what kind of a country we are but I will
tell you
this when I was a younger
person I'm not whitewashing or
glamorizing or romanticizing the America
I grew up in but I will tell you this
there was a greater consensus that we
were not supposed to be but this is not
just about race this is about everything
when I was growing up obviously we've
never been without racists and
homophobes and anti-semites and bigots
of course we've never been without those
people we're human beings but when I was
growing up there was a greater sense we
weren't supposed to be those things and
you had a sense that neither major
political party would give uh the
megaphone a major megaphone to anyone
who spoke from those kinds of places
today largely largely because of social
media people have felt now free to give
voice to to Sentiments that when I was
growing up at least there was a healthy
sense of shame in the country and we
knew you know yeah we should try not
there's no shame anymore there's no
shame and and some and there is such a
thing as healthy shame and that's what
disturbs me that people feel so
permitted to express views that are so
morally repugnant to a conscious person
do you think that it's better if people
don't express morally repugnant views
because my it's my it's my assumption or
maybe it's my guess that it's better to
hear people Express bad views so you can
challenge them or at least so you know
who they are and what they're thinking
as opposed
to people that don't express their bad
views and and essentially are hiding you
know bigoted or or whatever thoughts I
think it's better if if we know what
people are saying and where they're
coming from and so that way we can push
back on the ideas or so that way you can
avoid those people like I'd rather know
if someone didn't like them well I think
social media has changed all that I
think before social media there would be
a degree on which I would agree with
that social media when people are saying
these things for the clicks we you know
it's like I remember hearing Sasha Baron
Cohen say if Hitler were alive today
he'd be taking out 30C on Facebook we
some truly truly hateful things uh are
being said in a way that I do not
believe makes for healthier Society so
this is this was one of the big stories
October 2021 Biden secretly flying
underage migrants into New York in Deb
of night they had Westchester County
Police standing by as passengers were
arriving and this was just the first we
well that's the New York Post though so
I'd have to read that Tim I can't if the
New York Post writes an article like
that I don't know I I mean I I'm did
trust me I mean I will follow up on a
lot of this but I don't look at an
article in the New York Post and go oh
that's totally what's happening I don't
know you know I I I find that like I
have a lot of love for Humanity in
general just in general I see humans
eyeballs and I see like Consciousness
but concept NBC is sufficient though
right there's a well we let's go no that
that's disturbing and I and I don't see
it as a left right issue that that's
disturbing that's disturbing I think I
think this is one of the reasons why Joe
Biden's failing in the polls I think
more and more people are waking up to
realize that you know although it was
initially reported by the New York Post
and many people I mean your opinion
seems to be lower of them NBC News had
the story two days later confirming
basically the same thing and it's only
gotten worse and when I when I first
hear that Joe Biden or I should say his
administration because I don't know to
what level he actually knows is actually
engaged in the practice of what where do
we want he smuggling uh uh noncitizen
and I'll be very very careful I'm very
very enlight with my language children
who are not from this country and do not
have status are being flown in by the
Biden Administration in the dead of
night to various states without the
consent of the people who live there or
the local government sparking bipartisan
outrage this sounds criminal I think the
reason uh this is actually exactly what
I was talking about that people love
want to love and want to be there for
all the other people but there's this
concept called toxic compassion that
I've been thinking about for the last
couple years where it's like you want to
help everybody and then you end up
helping no one and and people are so
obsessed with helping every person that
comes by that it ends up like a white
tailed deer
overpopulation out we destroy so I'm I'm
very I I just don't think we can help
everyone and I don't even think we can
help most people I I I we have limited
time so I would like to move on to some
other subjects and then definitely get
into the area of the media you're
polling so but one thing I did want to
uh ask you about was your position on
one of the big culture War issues in
this country is in Florida they
announced that that that they would be
barring certain books from curriculum
that contained adult materials this
resulted in big headlines like this
about uh well this is not the one uh
Orlando newspaper publishes spread of
673 Books banned in Florida county in
2023 I was curious uh if you knew a lot
about what was going on Nationwide with
the removal of certain books from school
curriculum and what your thoughts were
I'm very much against book Banning I
think book Banning is is is basically
fascist Behavior some the books that are
being banned there's a uh there'll be a
suggestion of homosexual feelings so
they call it so so they call it
pornographic and something CH children
shouldn't read I trust uh teachers and
Librarians and I don't like the idea of
the US government or state government
telling Librarians or teachers what they
can teach you don't you don't think
there's you don't think we should have
laws on like what about a Playboy like
if a Playboy was in a Grade School would
that be an issue a Playboy magazine yeah
yeah as a parent I'd have a big big
problem with a Playboy magazine what if
what if there was a book being given to
middle schoolers that depicted giving
I I yeah well okay once again
if yeah I wouldn't want my child to read
that and I definitely would be wanting
to work on this is the book okay that's
that's School Board that's not
government not the US government or or I
don't want the US government and I don't
want the state Governor telling me the
books can not be uh taught if I were a
parent and my I am a parent if I if my
child in the eighth grade I would
definitely be going to the school I
would definitely be working with the
school board and I and I definitely
would have a problem with
that is it what if the school board if
it doesn't do anything about it then do
you have to appeal to the state I don't
want the I don't want a governor telling
uh uh colleges what classes they can
teach this isn't colleges this is no in
even yeah no I don't think the governor
is to be telling schools what they can
teach in the eighth grade I would have a
problem with that but that's school
board and then you elect people to your
school board if you had a a child
between the ages of 10 and 12 and the
teacher was providing them instruction
on how to use anonymous gay sex apps and
would you call the police on that on
that teacher I would I would definitely
go to the principal right away police I
have a problem with bringing the police
into that going to the principal you
better believe I would and I would show
up at the school board as well so so
reason why I bring up these these are
very specific examples uh this book is
gay uh we have this story from uh ABC
parents call cops after teacher offers
this book is gay to middle schoolers in
Illinois this book provides instruction
on uh for the use of uh gay dating apps
for anonymous sex and these are middle
schoolers these are these are 10 11 and
12 year olds so the parents finding out
that the teacher was doing this I mean
that's that's pedophilia that's that's
grooming behavior that that is outright
egregious and illegal when I I I don't
even want to say conservatives but but
it seems to be the case when uh let's
say someone like me I'm from Chicago and
I grew up with a Democrat family when I
find out that adults are providing
children this kind of stuff I say that's
a bad thing we shouldn't allow that
however for some reason I end up with uh
we had the woman um what was her name
from the majority report Emma vigland
Emma vigland came on and actually
defended that these books be kept in
Middle Schools no I would not agree with
Emma biglin yeah I think she hadn't read
the book either when she made that
statement could so this is the this is
the culture war is and the reason why I
bring it up is I often find that people
who would align themselves as more
Democrat or left leaning are not
familiar with the books in question that
are being challenged by parents and so
you end up with these stories that are
not correct they'll say something like
you know oh To Kill a Mocking Bird and
it's like I I I'm not I'm not concerned
at all about ideas and philosophy you
know I think critical race Theory as a
philosophy it can be taught in schools
but as uh as practice I don't think
that's appropriate so the criticism
became with Florida it it's not that
they had books on critical race Theory
it's that they had critical race
practice in books which but what are you
calling critical race practice practice
so uh for instance there's a uh what was
one example we had um I forgot the
woman's name uh was it azra nanii yeah
that was her name one of the a lot of
the books that they were bringing into
Florida would say something like you
know we have the classic math problem
where it says a train leaves Cincinnati
traveling 50 miles an hour and a train
departs Pittsburgh traveling or whatever
and you know at what point do they pass
but now what the books are doing it'll
say Evan is white and has been detained
by police two times in the past year
Jamal is black has been detained 17
times what percentage of the times have
police been racist and these are the
kinds of questions that are being put in
books so in so this is called Praxis
where the idea of the ideology is
embedded in a separate subject parents
were upset saying hey this is
ideological and not relevant to the
subject of science or math we don't want
this as part of the curriculum too soon
and so then what ended up happening is
they say okay well we're going to remove
this from curriculum but then of course
the media reports it as Republicans
banned books but well but see even the
way we're contextualizing the
conversation I don't think is very
helpful I don't think it's a left right
issue for instance if you are a parent
and you don't want your child in the
seventh grade reading a book about
I mean that's just to me that's
not a left right issue that the child is
learning about that in school but to me
as an American not as a left Winger but
as an American I do want my child to
learn for instance about unequal
application of Criminal Justice uh when
it comes to race if a black person is uh
given a sentence in a in a in a uh
courtroom in the United States it that
black person is liable to have a 20%
longer sentence what I didn't like about
what you said was it was a specific Pro
projection onto the police when not
every policeman is racist that's
practice however yeah the idea though
that the white person is stopped so much
less than the black person I don't have
a problem with kids learning that in
high school but shouldn't those
shouldn't topics like that be their own
subject as opposed to mixed into other
topics because what end up H what ends
up happening is if you're teaching kids
m math and you're
adding additional subcontext then that's
then then you end up with with people
that aren't learning the subject they're
supposed to be learning and that's part
of why our our our schools have such a
problem with with making uh making test
scores and have we have kids that are
graduating without you know that can't
read at grade level some can't read
functionally can't read at all and a lot
of it is because of these kind of means
of teaching this for the for the type of
the type of teaching and the framework
they use it's it's part of the reason I
mean there's a lot of reasons there's
there's there's parents aren't aren't
making sure their kids are getting to
school and stuff parents aren't you
aren't taking care of of their parental
duties there's a lot of things opioids
there's yeah kids dropping out and stuff
like that absolutely there's a lot of
reasons but you are you do see the more
a whatever institution whatever you're
dealing with whether it be an
institution or whether it be
corporations with their HR departments
focusing on on like Dei and stuff like
that when you have
when you have those type of departments
and that kind of focus you are taking
away some of the at least a portion of
the resources that are supposed to go to
actually teaching and you're putting
them to things that don't teach them or
or hinder the them teaching because if
that were its own class in like whether
it be social studies or whatever in
civics or whatever um if the the the
type of of you know awareness or social
justice was was its own class that's one
thing but if you're mixing in with other
things then you're going to have have it
watered have a problem with uh this
sorry entertaining you're making some
some some points that are understandable
however the what those of us on the left
are are arguing the children should
learn for instance our racial history in
this country well no one's arguing
against
that yes many people are arguing against
that I'm sorry many people are arguing
against that and there's this hysteria
about critical race there and they think
just teaching people about the history
of slavery in the United States
that's do you know that there are
schools there are schools I remember I
was in South Carolina and there's a law
that if any any child goes um to the
teacher and says that made me
uncomfortable that then the teacher
cannot teach that book yeah and that
came from the left because of people
that like from from microaggressions and
stuff like that if you feel
uncomfortable in a in a class it was it
was the left leaning people that wanted
I kind of agree with that actually yeah
the left people like point is a child
all that that has to happen in that case
is that the parents tell the child tell
tell the teacher this makes you
uncomfortable once a child gets into
High School you start reading books
about things that I mean part of
literature part of art part of movies
there are some things that are going to
make you uncomfortable and if you know
unit States let me let me let me do you
agree with critical race Theory critical
race theory was just something that had
to it's so misunderstood it was
something that had to do with a legal
theory that people were talking about in
like law school um but there are things
that have to are you not familiar with
the the ideology of critical race Theory
it has to do with the idea that many
things are seen through and filtered
through the the um through the lens of
of race but many things that that
parents had been lining up to complain
about in um in in school boards around
the country just were anything that had
to do with race and calling it in in
this almost hysteria about critical race
Theory I think there's a big difference
between critical race Theory and
teaching children the truth about the
history of the United States which I
believe regardless of our politic itics
is a is a requirement for conscious
citizenship so outside of perhaps there
are a lot of ignorant people who aren't
they're complaining for a variety of
reasons I won't speak to them I'm sure
they exist the political stances taken
by uh many people uh that were fighting
books on critical race theory was what's
called critical race practice and that
is to take the ideology from Kimberly
kensaw and Derrick Bell and apply it
into schools through science and math
and other unrelated to say social
studies so you you'd end up with a lot
of uh uh political commentators saying
things like my position for instance
take the literal book critical race
Theory and bring it to any school you
want and let children read it and even
give them a lesson on it but critical
race practice was when they did like a
math problem like you were just talking
about right yeah so the the issue I take
with critical race theory is that it is
an abhorent racist ideology that uh
advocates for segregation and the
critical race practice was to take that
ideology and apply it and teach children
we ended up with two uh uh or I should
say we ended up with a wide range of
extremist beliefs that we saw uh
manifest throughout the country such as
uh what would they call it nonp and POC
groups they began actually creating uh
in seatt I think it was Seattle there
was a library where when people were
allowed to come if you were white you
had to go in a white room only and if
you were not white you went to the not
not white room in Dearborn Michigan you
had the digital cafes this was during I
believe it was during Co and they said
everybody come hang out online and talk
in a chat room but if you're white you
go in the room only for white people and
if you're not white you go in the room
only for not white people for instance
uh an example of this Derrik Bell
Pioneer of critical race Theory actually
argued that brown should not have
dismantled py versus Ferguson a core
component of critical race theories that
schools should remain segregated so in S
I believe it was Sacramento's School
District they created white racial
Affinity groups based on critical race
Theory I think I think that should be a
lot in schools and if teachers are
teaching critical race practice to
children I believe it's illegal under
the 1964 Civil Rights Act and should be
barred from schools yeah but what we end
up with once again is you're Banning
books conservatives are Banning books
they're trying to stop teaching our
history it's realistic but some of the
books that they're banning some of the
books that they're banning Grapes of
Wrath yes Grapes of Wrath is one of the
the top 100 uh most uh um band books
Grapes of Wrath the Portrait of Dorian
Gray because someone has a homosexual
feeling um or we even talking about to
Kill a Mocking Bird so I I I don't think
we have to separate this I mean some
things are just kind of outrageous no
matter what your politics are but other
things I think American children should
learn our history and I think they
should learn great great books of
literature great works of art um I think
we all agree okay good so we don't have
to turn this into a war but I think the
issue is if say r santis comes out and
he put this on
florida.com uh or I should say they did
actually I think no this is Ronda santis
the books they banned were gender queer
flamer this book is gay and let's talk
about it books that contained
pornographic and adult materials and
instruction on those things for junior
high school this is Middle School no I
wouldn't want that but so the issue then
becomes the W the media widely reports
he's just Banning books in general when
you get I mean this is this is Ronda
Sanz from his own mouth saying these are
the books we banned and why we banned
them but then all of a sudden the
corporate press just says he's Banning
books in general and and the
conversation shifts from we don't want
children getting access to adult content
to the perspective what you have is oh
they're trying to ban books like grapes
of that's not the perspect that's that's
not what I just said I agreed with you
that there are books that I would not I
don't I'm not comfortable with the
governor doing it but there are books uh
with over sexual or whatever uh at a
certain young age that I just would be
fine with the um uh with the school
board saying um too young this is like
um like you were saying when you were
younger ideas of like racism were just
shameful and that Society wouldn't allow
those things to get a mainstream
megaphone and now it's similar with
books we're in the age of
self-publishing people can can publish
ideas without a central Authority like
saying hey that's a little sh publisher
there's no gatekeeper yeah and so the
that we kind of have to to be more
vigilant in our censorship methods well
I think that that nothing is a
substitute for an ethical Revolution we
all have to just uh that's why the work
of just what is an ethical person you
can't there is no substitute for that I
I have I have a problem with with the
the your your talk of censorship just
because it's one thing to to like I
we've talked about you know what can go
into um libraries and stuff and it's one
thing to to curate what goes into school
libraries and stuff like that censorship
is a totally for an animal I think it's
a form of censorship curation well I
just want to General no I don't I mean a
library curates an art director curates
uh uh somebody curated what was on the
wall here oh yeah mostly me sensor is
mostly a neutral term it's just you're
you're looking at something and deeming
is this permissible or is it not in the
current situation no I think I think
curation is neutral censorship is not
neutral well you can censor something
and allow it so what you if you censor
something you're just deciding yes or no
censure versus censor um I think when
you sens censoring is just the act of
observing and deciding yes or no
censoring is when you specifically
removing information it can be good or
bad what about these great works of art
uh you were talking about the things you
were talking about many of us are upset
about things like to Kill a Mocking BG
Grapes of Wrath uh but we all agree on
that and I think we all agree on a lot
of the stuff yeah but so this is this is
more ambiguous I'm curious your thoughts
on this it's kind of hard to read I I
tried to find a higher resolution uh and
for the record I was right you were
wrong censure is a official rebuke or an
expression of strong disapproval yeah
but a censor CN O is just the act of
deciding yes or no you can say yes
that's okay but you still censored it or
you can say no it's not okay and you
censored it it's sort of the opposite of
what yeah c yeah and so sorry to
interrupt society's Tak this I think I
understand what you're saying they
become Society will try and tell you
that it means saying no it only means
saying no but it's just the act of
deciding yes or no is to censor yes but
by definition if you say no you are
censoring argue that you said it's
neutral but I don't think it's neutral
there's a reason why it's censored um um
I want to get uh uh this is this is a
more ambiguous example of from a book in
a school I'm curious your thoughts are
you able to see it I'm trying to find a
good high resolution image of it but
this is from a book called not my idea
particularly a page from the book about
contract binding you to whiteness it
says you get stolen land stolen riches
special favors whiteness gets to mess
endlessly with the lives of your friends
neighbors and loved ones and all fellow
humans of color for the purpose of
profit your soul sign below land riches
and favors may be revoked at any time
for any reason it depicts a uh hoofed
footed demon with fire on top of with
money on fire a Devil's Tail and a hand
reaching for a
handshake
no I think that's terrible so this is
critical race practice when they take
the ideology from Derek Bell or kimbley
khaw and they put in a children's book
and this is one of the books they want
removed from schools whiteness is a bad
deal it always was dude we can see your
pointy
tale this is what's in grade schools and
this is this is the the reason why like
this is the stuff that that as much as
conservatives are are trying to get
stuff out and there there is going to be
or there are going to be attempts by by
um more authoritarian conservatives to
try and attach their their limits on
people's rights and stuff like that
that's going to happen but at the same
time stuff like this your average person
doesn't even know like they're not even
aware and then when it's presented to
them by the media which you understand
exactly how how duplicitous and and and
difficult it can be with today's modern
media when it gets presented to the
average person by the media they do
everything they can to make this seem
like this isn't the situation they make
it seem like it's B it's all racists and
all bigots and blah blah blah but then
you you actually look into it and the
situation is no there's really
objectionable stuff being placed in put
in schools that parents are objecting to
and then the FBI goes after the parents
for protesting you know this is this
this is the government that that we have
right now this is the real federal
government FBI going after a parent
because his kid was was sex this is
state level so in Virginia uh uh lden
County are you familiar with the lden
County Conflict which G so lden county
is about 30 seconds from here lden
County Virginia and there was a uh I
believe she was a pre-teen girl was
raped in the bathroom by a boy wearing a
dress the conservative uh conservative
Center reported as a trans boy but I
don't think the boy was trans I think
the boy was like non-binary identifying
or something just wearing female clothes
and using the girls bathroom the thought
the school covered it up it led to a
huge Scandal which was a huge component
in why Northam didn't win re-election
and why yunan did uh the father got AR
Ed when he went to the school board
demanding to know why the school covered
up the rape of his daughter so these are
the these are these are the extreme
stories that are popping up for the
people who are you know attuned to it
the corporate press of course is not
talking about it so you know think and
they slander people that do of course
like I think much with what you
experience how they lie about you it's
so widespread it's actually hard to
break through I did just bring up this
site just to show you this not my idea
that the passage I just showed you this
is a children's book where they say this
about about whiteness and uh I do want
to talk about this and and this is I
don't know I figure I'd bring this this
story up to see what your thoughts are
there's a movie coming out called the
American Society of magical Negroes it's
got people very angry because in the
trailer for the film they say uh
actually let me let me see if I can just
play this and I'll get your thoughts on
it let's see if we have uh might have to
unmute the site no we're
good I know you you can feel their
discomfort
Aaron watching you walk through a room
full of white people was the most
painful thing I've ever seen excuse me
sorry I don't want to take you to a job
interview there's a recruiting class
starting right now and we got to get you
in
it welcome to the American
Society of magical
Negroes I don't really understand it's
easier to
sh what's the most dangerous animal on
the planet sure white people when they
feel uncomfortable white people feeling
uncomfortable precedes a lot of bad
stuff for us that's why we fight white
discomfort every day I'll pause right
there and say uh show this a meter
showing white tears next to a police
officer so the premise of this film is
that the most dangerous animal on the
planet is white people and a group of
secret magical black people have to use
magic powers to keep white people plated
otherwise the white people will turn on
them and kill them so this movie's got
everybody pissed off uh the root wrote
about it and they're actually angry many
well I shouldn't say they're angry but
there's a lot of criticism from more of
the left leaning people that it depicts
an interracial relationship which is
surprising I guess not really and then
the criticism from the right is that the
premise of the film is that white people
are the most dangerous animal on the
planet this is what people would refer
to as critical race practice in
mainstream media and film and and this
is a ma this is a major movie this is
like you know Hollywood level production
one of the problem the question that
comes up for me is what you were saying
before is it better that stuff be out
there and that people hear it you know
personally I think it's better you know
um but at the same time like stuff like
this like this is is is hidden from the
public and and until it it's burst into
an ugly form like this and it that book
which one not my idea that book with a
devil telling that kid you know I mean
it's it's all it's all so toxic and so
illiberal and there are people in and
the media misrepresents all of the
objections to it as coming from a place
of bigotry as coming from a place of
evil and stuff and I can understand that
so I understand that this is why when it
comes to a show like ours we have every
conservative in the world emailing us
asking us to come on and not a single
liberal emails emails us asking us to
come on we actively have to fight to get
liberals come on the show well wait a
minute let's look at me I'm I'm very
leftwing in my political views but I
agree with most of what that's why
you're sitting in this chair saying I I
mean this to me is it we're talking
about a lot of things here that I don't
even see as Left Right issues I agree do
you they've been turned into left right
issues but and so the issue is when you
have high-profile prominent liberal or
leftist commentators who know exactly
what we're talking about they will not
come on this show because they would
have to put themselves in a position
where they're in opposition to their
tribe do you consider well I you know my
own tribe is not very nice to me but you
see that's exactly it people who are
trying to remain within the circle of
the the dominant left ideology have to
agree with critical race Theory and if
they speak out against it they will get
canceled they will get banned from media
they'll get lied about they'll get
smeared well that's why I said earlier
if if we could just stay away from that
term H the the term is so is such a hot
potato it's not helpful it's it's what
we're talking about here doesn't help to
even talk about it in terms of critical
race Theory it seems to me but this is
what critical race theory is this is
well but it's but there are those who
would argue differently but they're
wrong well critical race practice this
is practice but but more more
importantly when like we have the book
we have uh Chris Kimberly crunch's book
critical race Theory the core ideology
and it explicitly talks about what the
ideology means what it represents what
their goals are Derek Bell of course
famously said he thought plusy V
Ferguson was wrong and he wants
segregation in schools so when someone
comes out and says I would argue
critical race theory is something
different they are lying do you there's
two things that that they could be wrong
too but anyone arguing in favor of
segregation I think is is doing bad
first of all I I wonder do you consider
yourself a liberal or do you consider
yourself a progressive well this is what
I feel I feel everybody needs to come
out of their silos right now okay I
think these these these labels are not
helping any of us I don't even think
they help us at this table I think this
table has been an example of the the
labeling is the one places where we've
gotten off and when we didn't have the
labels we were just talking As Americans
and I say that all the time you know I'm
running for president and I and I feel
that so strongly people say who do you
talk to I Don't Give a different talk
depending on if they black brown white
Jewish Christian Muslim gay straight
non-binary Rich poor I'm speaking to a
place in the American Heart the American
conscience American decency and I think
all of those labels are disserving us
right now so on a on a on a superficial
level I'm a progressive but I see stuff
now that just makes me
think nobody has a monopoly on truth and
nobody has a monopoly on this smugness
and arrogance and my way is right and
your way is wrong this almost
mean-spiritedness that I see in everyone
right now and I think we all need to get
off our high horses I think uh I agree I
think the issue is you know for us for
instance it comes down to the simp uh
simplic simplification of terms and
their General understanding so we end up
in this world where I am a I I when I
was younger I was a punk rock Anarchist
skateboarder uh listening to you know
Anti Flag and bands like that against me
baby I'm an anarchist I can still play
that song and I still know all the words
and uh now they call me far right so I
still wear the same clothes I don't
think of you I mean just hearing you
today I mean I don't know I don't watch
your show all the time because they're
lying right well they lie about me all
the time too exactly so they'll lie and
they'll say I'm a conservative despite
the fact that my politics are actually
fairly middle of the road yeah you know
I I have I have arguments with pro-life
individuals on a more traditionally
Democrat pro-choice position but that's
what I mean let's drop the let's drop
the labels aren't helping yeah getting
people locked into to boxes and silos of
what they think they are I think that's
a tactic used by people that want to
maintain control of a society and they
also are creating an artificial
dichotomy as a as a kind of screen to
hide the real division the real division
is the powerful versus the powerless the
real division is the corporate Elite
versus those struggling to get by AG the
real division is those who have capital
and access to more Capital versus those
who are locked into circumstances uh
that deny them the opportunity for
economic growth this what saw occupi
Wall Street man Tim you brought it up
multiple times they it was working
occupi was working and Bank of America
was shaking and then all of a sudden you
start to see identity politics they
wouldn't let me speak because I was
white they said you can't we've had too
many white people I was like I'm about
to read the Constitution and they that
made it worse and they like white guy
reading the
constition do there is another component
to this uh I agree with you on the
corporate Elite and those who struggle
but then there is the international
versus nationalist view where you appear
to be more of the internationalist
sentiment and Trump supporters appear to
be more of the Nationalist sentiment and
what what I mean by that is yeah you're
right I am nationalism is not a good
thing the one thing to love your country
patriotism is a good thing thinking your
country is better and the only one that
matters is not a good well that's not
nationalism I mean that there perhaps
there there's a better word for that I
think maybe chauvinism which I uh used
to be like uh bias for males or
something but now is typically represent
actually no I think chanism was
originally you boastful about your own
country but uh to clarify what I mean uh
Trump supporters love America and many
of them will say we're the best country
ever well we love America right but so
for me for instance uh I don't want
foreign war I don't think we should be
sending money to Ukraine I don't think
we should be engaged in the Middle East
in Syria I don't think we should be uh
occupying Afghanistan we shouldn't have
for as long as we did it's a disaster
Iraq all the same now you've got Lindsey
Graham calling for war R all that's bad
I don't think we should have economic
hitman going to South America I think we
should have uh legal immigration
everybody in the world can come here but
you got to come here through a process
so we can make sure the economy is
functioning and everyone's happy I think
we should have manufacturing brought
back I think that we should stop uh
sending our jobs and our factories
overseas through failed trade policies
help the American worker help the uh uh
you know your average working-class
individual but that also means we can't
just have poorest borders with th000
people coming in every single day that
negatively impacts the people all over
this country and we can see they're
angry over it where I come from
everything you just said was moderate
and many things that you just said that
I definitely think of myself as leftwing
agree with for some reason the media
calls me far right huh pardon the media
calls me far right they call me cooky
crazy you know well that's the thing
they're lying about everything this
National decide where they want to put I
kind of decide I'm not really a
nationalist I mean reading what actually
means it's the ideology that says that
the individual's loyalty and Devotion to
the nation state surpasses the
individual's other groups or interest so
like your family your your local
community should be the most important
thing to you yeah or the rest of the
world I don't I don't God created all
men equal our Declaration of
Independence says all men are created
equal and that's not just all Americans
are created
equal all men are created equal that's
our mission this is correct and
non-citizens who are in this country
like a tourist is a good example have
constitutional protection same as any
other person whether they're citizen or
not uh I suppose the the the challenge
then becomes I think it's fair to say
that American classically and
traditionally liberal uh worldviews
don't align with say like fundamentalist
Islam yes correct but if we have a poest
border where 10,000 people are coming in
every day eventually you end up with
communities that are overwhelmingly fund
fundamentally Islamic and will pass laws
that say uh result in female genital
mutilation right we see this we see this
in in in parts of the country that's my
concern about immigration we want people
to come here and integrate with the
policies and the plans that have worked
and help so many people but if
immigration is unchecked you'll end up
with uh um you end up with what's what's
the right word um sh law no no no uh
isolated districts that operate
unanimously so enclaves het Enclave is a
good word for rather than when our
grandparents like my grandparents were
eager to assimilate and
has has kind of be like an ugly word to
it or an ugly tone to it nowadays where
people the way I look at this this
conversation that one right there for
instance should be a
conversation that we should be able to
have without
anybody feeling like I have you know
there are there's a Yen andong here yeah
there's a Yen and Y here you know uh
President Eisenhower said the American
mind at its best is both liberal and
conservative
there are high-minded liberal views and
there are high-minded uh conservative
views and and I I think it's important
that we remember nobody owes it to you
to agree with you nobody has a monopoly
on truth and a lot of things can be true
at the same time that's how I feel about
the conversation we had about the books
in in in um middle school that's the uh
same to me about some of the racial
things you were talking about and the
things we're talking about now many
things are true at the same time and the
point the the founders vision was that
if we do talk about it we're all
educated uh we're all
thinking it what's happened is this
characterological way that we all jump
to a conclusion jump to an alignment
with a kind of knee-jerk um
identification with what we think our
side is supposed to think and that's
what's taking us down we should we
should be able to discuss these things
just listening to each other sometimes
we want to rush to what is the answer
and sometimes the answer is just the
quality of how we think about the
question and how we just Ponder and
reflect well that was right this is
right true what he said was true what I
just said is true both are true that's
called maturity that's called maturity
let's go to uh a very difficult subject
a what let's go to a very difficult
subject abortion all right uh so have on
your uh website here this is maran2
24.com
100% pro-choice uh do you want to just
break down for us what your view is on
abortion what it should be access I
think abortion is a moral
issue but I think it is a moral issue
that is between a woman and her
conscience the god of her understanding
um I believe it is an issue of private
morality and not public morality uh
traditionally in this country uh The
Divide between right and left people on
the right concern themselves more with
issues of private morality people on the
left issues of public morality like uh
that's why you find people on the right
talking about abortion talking about
homosexuality people on the left talking
about economic Justice is a moral issue
invading a country that didn't do
anything to you is a moral issue it's
kind of inverted now though well the
Democrats are pro you know funding for
Ukraine and well but see rep are anti
intervention see me even that that's a
can we just get more real and more deep
about it rather than seeing it they're
doing it with Israel and Palestine too
everything people people are trying to
make everything black and white now well
you said Republic the right tends to do
this the left tends to do that and I
would say a lot the specific issues I
didn't mean but are we going to stay
with abortion yeah yeah for sure okay I
just feel I trust the uh moral decision-
making of the American woman and I don't
think a government has any right to tell
a woman what to do with her body do you
think there should be any limits on uh
uh the amount of like how many weeks
before yeah and the states came up with
those limits and that's why I think what
we had with roie way was reasonable
so uh in your view do you do you think
it should be a ferally legislated or
codified issue pertaining to abortion
that should affect all states like uh
roie Wade for instance was
overturned as president would you
advocate for or sign a bill that would
federally codify roie way yes do you
think that there should be uh limits uh
how do you phrase this properly should
there be a time limit like after 16
weeks or 21 well there always was there
was was there was but do you think there
should be now is there is there when Yes
except when the health of the health of
when health issues of Health are
involved so so uh let's say there's no
issue of Health a woman is pregnant
would it be what what's what's your view
when people start talking about this
late term abortion thing you've got no
do I think someone a a woman who's eight
months pregnant just decides you know I
don't want to do this should she be able
to have an abortion no but that doesn't
happen so then would you have an issue
with it being made
illegal well it it was during the during
when roie Wade was
legal that was not possible the states
had the states had their their their
limits if if a republican Congress said
okay it never happens we're going to ban
all abortions after six months no
because you've got to keep it with
medical I mean when you see what's
happening with Kate Cox in Texas now I
don't think a government should get
between a a woman and medical decision
this is the first I've heard of Kate Cox
tell me about it I think Tim's looking
it up right now yeah Texas Tribune Kate
Cox's case reveals how far Texas intends
to go to enforce there judges saying
what that woman has to do and she has to
leave Texas to get an abortion that was
necessary and that was uh for her health
and for her the the viability of her uh
being a being fertile in the future ah
yes but this was I believe the Supreme
Court ruled the doctor did not
demonstrate a medical need the doctor
the doctor that's the
a a bunch of men who are judges in Texas
should not be determining what the
doctor calls medical need and what the
do what the doctors were claiming was
that her future fertility was at stake
yeah so that's not for a bunch of judges
in Texas to say you therefore have not
demonstrated Med medical need because
they don't consider that a medical issue
and then this is what kills me why most
of my conservative friends say we don't
want government overreach to me that's
extraordinary government overreach that
was an issue about that woman and her
medical care and those old men and and
on some Court in Texas saying that's not
I wouldn't I wouldn't go that far but I
do I do uh think when it comes to
medical issues it it's being debated
right now conservatives saying it's uh
Tri uh TR 18 or something like that I'm
I'm not familiar with the uh uh the
ailment of the child and they're
concerned that it could negatively
impact her uh fertility and and the
child may not even live that long
there's a possibility the child could
live long but not they're not sure and
so that's that's that's a very it is a
tough moral position that I don't I
that's tough for me that's tough for me
I just don't to me it's not even tough
to me it's government get your hands out
of this but let's let's let's go back
because I'm going to I'm going to press
you on this if the Republican said if
you think lat term abortion elective
later abortion never happens then how
about we have a ban elective abortion
after 6 months is hereby made illegal
but they that that is already under
under roie Wade that was already true
the states had uh their limits and then
beyond that there had to do with with uh
what a doctor had to say sure but is
that is yes you would agree with a law
Banning abortion elective abortion after
six months I I don't want to give you
the set time frame you can choose
whatever time frame you want after after
a certain after a certain period of time
yeah my concern is with um the
definition of of what it means to be a
medical issue and how do we how do how
do how do we protect against abuse of
the system I've never been been one to
say that potential crimes of an indiv
individual should then in infringe upon
someone else's rights for say like
medical care and I'm not talking about
elective abortion I'm saying you know if
a woman has a very serious disease and
is going to Hemorrhage or something and
the doctor's like ma'am you're not going
to make it we have to operate now I
think it's absurd to be like but that
would abort the baby so we got to talk
to a judge or something the concern
there however is there have been
instances where people have tried to
argue mental health qualifies and have
tried to use that to get elective
abortion it may be rare but this is the
concern conservatives have and pro-life
individuals have is preventing abuse of
the system and abortion as contraception
no matter what law you pass there's
going to be abuse of the system I agree
so that's not a reason not to pass a
good law I I completely agree I
completely agree I think uh yeah the the
idea that some people will break the law
means that everyone must now abide by
this har standard doesn't necessarily
solve the problem no that's ridiculous
but there are concerns for instance in
Colorado the new law now and I
understand what you're saying about roie
Wade currently uh abortion in Colorado
is one of seven states without any term
restrictions as to when a pregnancy can
be terminated it is uh colloquially
described as uh uh restriction and
Limitless abortion meaning a woman could
be without many any medical health issue
and at 9 months and legally get an
abortion and and and to the point of
birth so uh the famous example of this
was when um uh I think it was rep Tran I
could be getting your name wrong in
Virginia argued to a judge that a baby
could be at the point of birth and the
doctor could terminate the life of the
baby under Virginia's bill the bill
didn't pass uh Governor Northam gotten a
lot of heat over this I think I actually
have the the story this is right here
from 2019 Virginia governor faces
backlash over comments supporting late
term abortion Bill where whether
intentionally or not he actually
described postbirth abortion which is
not a real thing but he basically
described just killing the baby in his
statement on radio he said the baby
would be delivered resuscitated and then
they would decide if they would like to
terminate oh come on he did say that yes
but yeah but that does
not that and he said it's not a real
thing well no no no post post birth
abortion is just killing a baby yeah so
but that's what Northam actually
advocated for oh it's absurd so this
this is this issue like this comes up in
the press and just like all the other
issues you'll end up with me like you
know traditional liberal fairly
pro-choice but like I think there should
be safe legal rare and you see a story
like this and I'll say okay this man's
lost his mind you got to vote him out of
office then the media claims he never
said it they claim it's a lie they say
nobody wants this it never happens and
we're sitting here like we got the guy
on his his audio of him uh basically uh
he says they're done in cases where
there may be severe deformities I can
tell you exactly what would happen the
infant would be delivered the infant
would be kept comfortable the infant
would be resuscitated if that's what the
mother and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physician and the mother oh so they're
talking about severely deform
babies it we we can I will give him all
of the benefit of the doubt and
everything and we will say the most
deformed a baby could be he's still
talking about after it's already born
and Alive bring it to another room and
then talking with a doctor whether you
want to end its
life it's a question
of you know to what degree do we accept
deformities to be terminated after birth
right I mean this is his quote CNN has
it uh you know what is what is uh severe
deformity defined as legally I mean is
Down syndrome considered that to that
degree oh God
no but I mean one of the most common
forms of reasons for abortion is the
baby is diagnosed with down you know now
we have sonograms and we have um what is
that other one called not sonogram the
they know so much now do in your opinion
if a woman found out that her uh her
healthy viable pregnancy the child had
Down syndrome do you think that's reason
for an
abortion I would have the child I would
have a I would have a Down syndrome
child if I found out I had Down syndrome
but should it be legally allowed for a
woman to terminate a pregnancy that is
otherwise healthy if the child has Down
syndrome to me the issue of abortion
whether a whatever the woman's decision
has to do with the time and what that's
statee determines us the time so that is
the reason and then her reasoning is her
reasoning so any reason no reason at all
until a certain period of time so like
once a child is viable and this is
obviously a baby they could be delivered
and live that's a whole different thing
I completely agree the argument we've
we've run into with progressives is they
actually go beyond that uh even a friend
of mine argued that a child a baby is
not alive until it's delivered therefore
a baby at 9 months could be aborted if
the woman l i don't agree with that
a lot of the progressives and it's not a
lot mind you but a couple I know I see
this is where we this this only bolsters
and fortifies this separation well
progress I think this is healing huh I
think this is healing that's why I ask
uh hearing hearing from you someone
who's running for for the Democratic
party saying we don't want these things
is exactly what I hope it is a moral
issue of course it's a moral issue this
is what we need support roie W and I
think a woman's right to abortion should
be codified by law and I would do
everything the IDE of a government
telling a woman uh what she has to do is
very difficult for me when I was uh uh
when the roie way decision came out I
was more on the side of perhaps it's
good the states can figure out for
themselves and have more nuanced laws
but now I don't know if I'm for roie
Wade but I'm certainly for the federal
uh legislation and adjudication of when
a a baby has constitutional rights so uh
I believe life begins a conception
however I'm much more libertarian on the
issue which is why I'm concerned about
having to go to a doctor or panel of
judges to determine medical issues it's
it's tough I I don't have a good answer
but
uh excuse me I just lost my train of
thought we we're having a lot of we're
hearing everything that we said would
happen with DOs is already happening
great suffering among women you know
women used to have you know when I was
growing up it was simply before before
roie way um and I think I was a little
girl at the time but certainly before it
was uh legal it was about rich women
getting safe abortions and poor women
getting unsafe abortions I remember what
I was going to say excuse me I believe
the federal government and the Supreme
Court needs to issue a ruling on when
life begins they have to because the
14th Amendment under its basic reading I
believe protects the constitutional
rights of The Unborn it says no person
it does not say citizen shall have their
rights infringe without DPR process but
if we were to interpret that verbatim
textually that would mean that a if a
baby is viable then only through
adjudication in a court could the woman
seek abortion even if it was for medical
reasons yeah this says in a legal
medical reason is uh someone that can do
things a human person is usually able to
do in law so a baby wouldn't I mean an
infant in the womb wouldn't be a person
if they can't do any you know you got to
be able to do things that a human can do
but then a seven Monon old b a seven
yeah it doesn't I'm sorry to interrupt
born babies are persons yeah yeah but in
womb in utero it doesn't have legal
personhood yet because it doesn't have
the ability to do things that a person
would do I don't know but that's not
been adjudicated that's your opinion and
my argument is op and the Supreme Court
needs to rule on their opinion as to
when they actually would that's my point
legal personhood for babies in utero
that'd be if there's a baby that's 9
months gestated in the womb and a baby
that's 9 months gestated that's already
been delivered you cannot say that they
are different biological entities the
only thing that's different is the layer
of Flesh between the birth itself you
know Robie was
working Ruby R was working I I disagree
clearly when you look at conservatives
and the outrage and the sentiment it
wasn't working for
them I always felt like that was a
minority you could say that I mean a lot
of people slavery was working for a lot
of people but the but but actually it a
lot of people were against civil rights
legislation only only I think % of the
country had slaves
so for the babies that were getting
aborted either just like slavery wasn't
working for the slaves abortions not
working for the babies that are getting
aborted so you don't think that abortion
should be legal under any circumstances
I'm pro-choice to for the first first
trimester and then at the end of the
first trimester my argument is more so
if the baby can survive on its own you
shouldn't kill it that's a tough
argument CU if you don't have
electricity unless there's
medical yeah and and and then my concern
is like I I agree with you I think the
idea that a doctor says to you like hey
you're about to die better call the
judge and get an emergency horrifying
that's just insane I mean but that I
suppose if the Supreme Court ruled under
the 14th amendment that The Unborn are
legal persons because if if a baby is
born premature at what what's what's the
earliest they they they can be they
they've gone now like 30 weeks or
something I don't Sheamus knows way
better than me but I think 26 weeks 26
right something like that is that a
legal person it is uh so
if a baby is born as premature as
premature can be and it is alive and you
kill it you will be charged with with
generally between 23 and 24 weeks and
you know that like right now they have
the technology to do uh artificial wombs
they've raised you know they've they've
gestated Lambs in artifici that's the
thing just cuz they can take your three-
week old fetus and make it gestate in a
tube doesn't mean it's like a viable yes
it the power goes hold on I'm not even
arguing no no no no no a premature child
can be put in a safe place where it
survives on its own you got to feed it
and everything but a premature baby is a
legal person yeah it has the protections
of personhood the only difference
between a baby six months that was born
premature and a baby six months still in
the womb is the layer of Flesh between
it it's the birth itself in which case
I'm I I actually I actually think the
Supreme Court we currently have may may
argue the 14th amendment protects the
due process rights of the unborn after
viability which is not too dissimilar
from roie Wade but this results in after
16 weeks or maybe 20 a woman who wants
an abortion for any reason even medical
the would have to go through a due
process system uh no I just don't think
the government should be involved there
I suppose the issue is the due process
rights of persons you know and if not if
if a if a baby after six months is
considered a person if it's outside the
womb then why wouldn't it be inside the
womb and then does a doctor have the
right to kill someone without due
process a doctor takes a hypocritic Oath
a doctor is not who who says to who
suggests such well the baby has to die
in the abortion but the if the doctor is
suggesting that procedure there is some
medical reason having to do with the
mother or the child well I agree with
you right and so in this circumstance
man excuse me frog my throat imagine
there's a woman who's 6 months pregnant
the baby is is VI can survive on its own
the woman the doctor says there is an
issue where if you continue this
pregnancy right now 97% chance you die
in a in in in a week we need to abort
now otherwise you will die the baby can
survive you will die but no if this if
that baby that baby could be delivered
right now I mean why couldn't the baby
be delivered right now well I agree then
in which case we would say no to the
you're saving the baby and you're saving
the mother I I it's interesting because
I think you you actually agree 80% with
many of our pro- life runs yeah I feel
that way about so many things right and
it's just divide the media divide
creates hyperpolarized views of what it
should be it's not just the media who
does it it's it's not just the media who
does it no it's the activist too I think
I totally I totally agree with you
because because what we're because
really what what it boils down to we are
talking about you know the edges here
when it comes to you know most abortions
are at form of birth control most
abortions happen early
um the majority of but then when you
start talking to like you know partial
birth abortions or whatever they are the
the edge cases and so they're they're
it's not the the the primary concern
these things tend to come up when you're
dealing with political conversations you
know there's another thing about social
media I'm just thinking I would bet you
that somebody's going to take something
I say here to said here tonight I'm just
sure of it I was say thinking my God
this is why people said don't you know
they're
out of cont they're going to show me
agreeing with Tim P about something out
of context and oh my god look she's one
of them I me there's already this this
this meme about me that actually I'm a
Christian Republican and I I'm some kind
of mole or something you know this is
why liberal that's a large part of the
problem and that's also social media did
that I mean somebody did that with
Israel and Palestine for me the other
night one sentence out of context and
then
one slip of the tongue or one you know
like well misspoke that one word and
you're you know you're dead in the water
politically so we're on the other side
of the fire this is this is why many
liberals don't want to come on the show
yeah because they know I understand now
they have to the like you can't say no I
didn't say it it just doesn't work you
got to keep making media keep doing it
to to to reinforce who you are that's
the I believe that's the way to
counteract spin it's it's actually you
can't counteract SP you can't really
ever coun well you can you can diminish
it by making your own media and being
control your own platform think about
that a lot that so the issue with spin
is that the corporate press will always
do what it does they are interested in
either their political narrative or
their clicks and what clicks will they
get from saying Marian Williamson gives
reasonable view on moderate position
nothing it's not just the corporate
press either because sometimes what I've
seen in my life with all those is the
corporate press will say it but people
who like to think of themselves as
sophisticated
and invulnerable to social uh social
media manipulation are so vulnerable to
it they'll see one Anonymous tweet or
one article on the Internet is though oh
well then that's true y um it's just so
debased our level of of public dialogue
and what's wrong with we don't why do we
all have to agree on every little thing
we don't and I see in politics I I see I
have never voted for anyone expecting
that I agreed with them on everything
I've never voted for anyone expecting
that during their term in office they
would agree with me on everything we're
living in a time when you have to line
up and if you don't if you agree on any
little thing or like we were just
talking about somebody will take
something a clip on the on the you know
like I could be tonight right I could
hear tomorrow from my team it went viral
a million people saw you say something
out of context it's but that this my
advice would just be screw those people
well which is which is when you're not
running for office this has certainly
been my feeling I mean an author but
it's sad for politics because it keeps
it keeps people of nuance and and deeper
reflection so this sort of it it
disqualifies you this is why my view is
just good versus evil when someone a
parent sees a book with a in it
given to their kids Stonewall honor book
and being given to middle schoolers and
that parent says you know I take issue
with this and they go to the school
board and they say I don't know why you
have this book in the curriculum I don't
think it's appropriate for children then
all of a sudden you get a wave of
activists in the media lying about what
happened those are evil people the
people who lie about you and
misrepresent you I believe that's evil
they are they are causing damage and
destruction to this country they are
harming you who uh uh you know obviously
you're trying to do good you're trying
to help people you're trying to be a
good person and we respect it
tremendously but the media thinks you're
a threat to their power I shouldn't say
the media but elements of the political
establishment political media industrial
complex absolutely I think these people
are evil I find the good and evil thing
to even be too polarizing it's but it is
evil it's just a simplification method
to divide people because we all have it
within us we can all turn on a dime stay
with right and wrong given that there is
evil in the world and I do believe
there's evil in the world I I agree with
you that we could even though believe me
I'm watching it I'm living it right now
I'm living it with the way the uh the
corporatized political party system is
you know keeping me out of the
conversation planting stories uh
planting people in your all of that I
see it as wrong I don't see it as evil I
see it as evil I mean look uh I think
you are a good person we we in 2020 you
in 2019 the primaries and everything we
we we watched you uh we had Michael M
here yesterday who said that he thinks
you're so wonderful and fantastic you've
helped so many people and the media lies
about everything we we none of us here
or any of our friends have any issue
with disagreeing with you we think we
disagree we I you know I and I disagree
all the time get to it but so here's my
issue I don't think I'm right about
everything I certainly think I'm right
about a lot but I think I'm wrong about
a lot too and so what I think goodness
would be is recognizing that there's a
strong possibility I'm wrong about
everything therefore the best outcome
for the people of this country for the
world for the working class and even the
wealthy we want everyone to succeed and
and and strive and uh uh this means we
must be as honest as we can advocate for
what we believe and represent the
positions of others as best we can so if
you tell me your position on you know
abortion or race or whatever I want to
make sure I have it exactly as you're
you're saying it we we we'll break down
the core argument let the people hear it
and then they can say you know what
Marion's actually right about that I
agree because then they can make better
decisions which a rising tide lifts All
Ships what we're seeing with the
political what did you call the
political media industrial complex and
it is that what they're saying is I
don't care if she's right I deserve the
power so lies exactly correct trick
people into giving us the power and
we'll do what we want because we're
smarter than you that's that is that is
totally correct I you know now just to
clarify because I'll clip you I said I
say that's evil you said they're doing
wrong I think it is evil for someone to
trick people into stealing power well
let's talk about it in terms of the
foundational principles of the United
States we could stay away from right and
wrong good and evil and go right to
undemocratic it is an assault and an
undermining of democracy so I think you
know the founders and I've heard you
actually I heard a clip of you the other
day because I said oh I want to look a
little bit before I go on his show and
you were talking about and you were
talking about the Declaration of
Independence and first principles and
total agreement
so the founders did not expect that we
would come to the quote unquote right
decision every time but as Jefferson
said the only safe repository for power
is in the hands of the people yeah so
the whole idea of public education the
whole idea of free speech the whole idea
of a free press the whole idea of
freedom of assembly was so that we could
discuss things that we would have
critical uh thought processes that were
that were educated and so what the
founder said is if that's the case and
we really have the right to discuss
these things more often than not the
truth will out there's something so
profound about that so this corporatized
media and and and social media um uh
supression of Truth smearing of people
mischaracterizing people and believe me
I don't think anybody knows it more than
I do actually is a way of suppressing
the Democratic process agreed I'm
concerned about the public school
because you were saying education is key
but like this John Dewey Rockefeller
public school thing that got built in
like the late 1910 1913 not the founding
father's vision of how education would
happen creates uniformity of thought
it's doesn't build critical thinking
necessarily it creates centralization of
Doc of indoctrination well it was a
post-industrial thing it was really
creating workers more than creating crit
the Bell Rings The Shift Change what's
the best way to create factoris how do
you inspire critical thinking
great
teaching great teachers that's why I
have so much respect for teachers we are
going to go to super chats and take some
questions so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net
to go to the best song ever.com click
download your price 69 cents or whatever
you want to give and you can buy the
song to help support our work and our
cultural endeavor it is it this is the
final final run it's the home stretch we
if everybody bought that song right now
we would shatter our way into the hot
one 100 so um if you want to support us
that's how you do it otherwise you know
feel free not to but I asked what can I
say all right let's let's grab some
super chats we got Clint Tor says howdy
people dearest chat I must leave you why
I cannot say where you cannot know how
long will I be there I haven't decided
but the one thing I can tell you is that
anytime you hear the wind blow it will
whisper the name timcast and so let us
part with a love that will echo through
the ages see you later Clint that is one
hell of a super chat I think that's a
quote from something it's what is it
from no it's two two super chats Raymond
g Stanley Jr says Tim now that these now
that those people pulled and the
mediaite readers will be like who's Tim
p and why would would he be influential
it'll expand the reach of you and Jack
so uh this organization I I'm being told
it's like affiliated with Ronda sanz's
campaign or not his campaign is super
pack they did a poll
and they they wrote this story up saying
uh Paul finds Tim p and Jack pic are not
influential and I'm just like now hold
on there gosh darn minute why would you
write a story about two people you think
are unknowns with no influence who's
going to click the IM someone wrote a
story and said you know John Aaron
Ferguson and Bill Durley are not
influential you'd be like who like why
would you click it but I will say the
funny thing is is what Raymond's
referencing the poll actually found and
this is wild despite the fact they're
saying no one knows who Tim Po is and
he's not influential the poll found one
in three people are familiar with me
which is freaky so I think the poll is
probably bunk but it certainly did not
produce the results they were trying to
claim it did yeah they they said it's
like 69% we're unfamiliar with po like
31% of people you ask knew who I was
that's crazy why did the Santa care if
you're in what was that about well I
don't know about him personally but uh
we are um not fans of the DeSantis
campaign and his staffers and his
surrogates I think they are just
despicable people absolutely despic
speak for yourself you said we I don't
know him personally I'd like to meet
campaign we got to have Christina Pasha
in here to defend herself cuz I am not
happy the way she ran San's campaign I
would like to talk to her to her face we
invited her before but I think she's
made it clear as to why she shouldn't be
on the show and it's because like you
know some sometimes we do want to get
some fans to call into the show but we
don't do full two-hour segments where we
just invite some random person off the
street to come and talk politics we
usually try to find someone who has a
body of work in some way you don't have
to have a million followers some people
come on the show they have like 3,000
you know or or none at all don't even
have a social media account but they're
doing something relevant work Christina
Pasha views herself as just a fan of of
politics she's on Twitter and having
flame Wars with like random Twitter
accounts get out here Christina no no
I'm not I'm not interested in grabb a
random flame War Twitter account having
him come on the show I'm very
disappointed in the way his campaign was
run I will admit that basically they're
this what they do they lie like the idea
that uh a polling agency affiliated with
his pack would make some ridiculously
stupid story saying Tim pool is not
influential it's just the like stupidest
thing I've ever heard like because like
I was saying mediaite published a story
saying Paul finds Tim pool is not
influential well then why would anyone
click the story who wants to read about
a guy they never heard about for no
reason to find out a guy they don't know
about has no relevance how many people
did they pull for that I don't even know
but like the point is would you read an
article that says Paul finds John
Ferguson does not is not known by you
you'd be like yeah you're correct yeah
they used your name on purpose cuz they
knew it would get clicks exactly which
contradicts the poll and the poll found
that one in three people actually do
know who I am that's kind of insane to
think about and they frame it as though
Republicans don't trust Tim P I'm not a
republican I don't like Republicans
either why are they making this fake
this fake story so what happens is you
have a uh Trump gets kicked off the
ballot in Colorado actually real quick
you know what are your thoughts on that
do you agree with Trump being what oh
the thing about the Supreme the court
saying he can't be on the ballot yeah I
think and certainly I disagree with uh
Trump politically EXT I I have extreme
disagreements but he is not been
convicted of insurrection and I think
that what is better for everyone is that
Donald Trump is uh given a fair fair
treatment before the law compl what I
believe so what happens with the
disantis camp is the ramaswami says I
will withdraw from the primary unless
they allow Donald Trump to be involved
Ronda santis was asked would you also
withdraw and he says no I earned the
delegates this is how it's played and N1
to win but I do think it'll be
overturned anyway I find that despicable
I think every Republican should refuse
to participate in an election for which
one person has been unconstitutionally
removed
well well you know we have our own stuff
going on on the Democratic side trust me
and I think what they're doing to you
and even Jen yuger despite his
constitutional arguments on citizenship
I think that's completely wrong and I
think they should have a primary yeah
but we have a system of justice I mean
this this case it's now in Colorado will
go higher and let the system play out I
mean I think that the that we have to
have some trust in the justice system
it'll be interesting to see what the
Supreme Court says but the Supreme Court
I'm sure will be weighing in on this
they could just say no we won't get
involved in Texas V Pennsylvania in 2020
the Supreme Court said not interested
shocking a lot of people are you
familiar with what happened in what
which one Texas V Pennsylvania was uh a
lawsuit in 2020 and 2021 pertaining to
procedural changes that violated the
Constitution and uh in in the elections
held by several States and the Supreme
Court said we will not weigh on it at
all and so that meant uh issues
pertaining to constitutional procedures
in federal elections went unanswered and
this is a huge component in why Trump
supporters think the election was stolen
it's it's a huge component as to why
January 6th happened at all it may be
one of the biggest if not the biggest
yeah if if the Supreme Court had heard
that case if they if they had actually
heard the case and just had a had a
decision on it I am willing to bet that
January 6th doesn't happen at all
there's no right this is 48 States
involved in a lawsuit well this is for
so 48 states were involved in a lawsuit
to the Supreme Court asking the Supreme
Court to weigh on the legality of
Executives and judiciaries altering
procedure and elections Texas argued
that the constitution gives unilateral
authority to the legislature to
determine how an election is run and the
legislature has to have final say on the
certification if the election is changed
outside of the purview of the
legislation the legislature the
legislative branch of the state must
approve those changes so in Pennsylvania
for instance you had changes to voting
laws in Georgia you had the governor
making changes Texas said how are we
supposed to participate in an election
when these states are in violation of
the rules of the election for which we
are participating and the Supreme Court
said not interested because the Supreme
Court was leaving it to the states to be
in charge of their
elections well this didn't answer the
question of uh the the Constitution says
the legislative branch has has the final
say the Supreme Court saying we don't
care if a governor ignores the
legislative branch outright says there
is no answer to be given as to whether
or not this violates the Constitution so
everyone's left in limbo shrugging like
yeah what do we do but those wait look
at what happened in 2000 the the
Constitution says that states are in
charge of their elections talk about
judal overreach the the Supreme Court
said Florida wouldn't couldn't count its
own votes that is unconstitutional came
and went though about and the the the
reason the the they had to stop is
because the end date came no they said
that because they felt it would be an
unusual burden on Bush I it you know I
got to be honest I just don't think I'm
old enough to to have that be relevant
to my view of what happened in 2020 yeah
so I absolutely respect your position on
it my point is so the Constitution
actually says the legislative branch is
up to the legislative branches of the
states to determine how the states
that's my point right not the governor
and not judges so if a judge changes the
rules to an election the question raised
by Texas was hey whoa whoa whoa the
Constitution and and per the Supreme
Court's own rulings you know the
legislative branch should be determining
the final outcome of their how the
actions are run not a judge changing at
the last minute and the Supreme Court
just said not interested and so this was
an original jurisdiction lawsuit it
wasn't an appeal there was no answer
given as to whether or not States uh the
legislative branch must be the the
principal factor in determining their
elections so you end up with 48 States
involved I they believe it was 48 Texas
V Pennsylvania and then every other
state joins sides either with
Pennsylvania or Texas uh amicus briefs
flying through the air and it was only
Thomas and Alo who said we need to
answer this question the rest said leave
us out of it so what happens Trump
supporters say the Supreme Court has
abandoned us they've not answered the
question of how the elections are
supposed to be run combined with the
fraud narrative and a bunch of other
things result in a lot of people losing
their minds but uh I agree with Phil I
think that if the Supreme Court weighed
in and gave a simple opinion then you
don't think that uh that Donald Trump
would have claimed that the election was
stolen he
would the crow would have walked over to
the capital the Supreme Court took the
case and rolled on the merits Donald
Trump would be president oh oh well okay
all right so fair enough but he I
certainly don't agree if they if they
had rule if they had ruled that it it
was if they had actually taken it and
said no it's fine Supreme Court ruled
that a governor does not have the right
to change how votes are counted without
the approval of the legislature Mike
Pence would have been required to send
those votes from numerous States back to
the legislature to approve the
legislatures were Republican and
probably would have partisan just sided
with Trump trump would have had nothing
to complain about because the Supreme
Court I believe the only correct ruling
and the reason why they didn't take it
up was that in Georgia you had the
governor issuing rulings on how the
election would be run in violation of
the Constitution it was the Secretary of
State also in violation of the
Constitution which says the legislative
branch runs the elections and determines
how they're so if the I think the reason
the Supreme Court rejected this is they
knew the end result would be not that
they would determine Trump as president
but that they would say only the
legislative branch decides immediately
then the legislative branches of these
states would say we hereby nullify those
results let me ask you a question the
Constitution says the states are in
charge does the Constitution say the
state legislature is in Char it says the
state legislature has final say on the
running of the elections yeah
specifically that's why that was that's
why there was a challenge brought
because the it wasn't the legislature
making the CH for instance in in
Pennsylvania this was big a lower court
judge ruled that the uh uh the the
universal mail and voting bill was
actually unconstitutional on the merits
but it was appealed by Democrat groups
to the state supreme court and the
Supreme Court ruled despite the fact the
Constitution does bar you mailin votes
we will allow this to happen that's why
Texas sued Pennsylvania saying whoa whoa
your own state constitution says you
can't have Universal mailin voting and
you're doing it anyway so they said
Supreme Court you need to stop this this
is in violation of their own
Constitution but maybe the state
legislature had given that maybe the
state legislature had they did all right
well if the state legislature had state
legislature had said to the election
board or to the Secretary of State or
had given that is the final say it is
not because the law of Pennsylvania
states that in order to amend the
Constitution legislatively there had
there's a series of procedures that must
be done the state legislature abandoned
the procedures for amending the
Constitution and decided to force
through a bill anyway it was a
bipartisan agreement between Republicans
and Democrats Republicans thought that
if they got rid of the single party
voting that the idea was someone could
go in and just hit all Democrat and then
throw their voted and not have to worry
about names the Republican legislature
said we'll give you Universal mail and
voting if you get rid of down down
ballot party voting however many people
in the state said whoa whoa you can't do
that that violates the Constitution this
is an unconstitutional deal between
Republicans and Democrats they went to
court and a lower court judge ruled
correct it is unconstitutional to have
Universal mail and voting Democratic
groups appealed to the state supreme
court who said no no no should be
allowed Texas that intervened and said
how can we be party to an election in
this country if a state's in violation
of its own Constitution and a judge
altered the rules in violation of the
Federal Constitution they asked for an
answer from the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court said not interested
everybody loses their minds because
Pennsylvania had the right to do what
Pennsylvania wanted to do Pennsylvania
does not have the right to supersede its
own
Constitution but the government is still
the government still has hold on if they
want to change the law they if
Republicans if Republicans right now in
the house voted to ban Free Speech would
you say that's okay no well the
Constitution protects us right but we
have a supreme court that's why there
are three co-equal branches of
government the Supreme Court would then
have a chance to weigh in on that and
would consider and would would say that
that law is unconstitutional what the
Supreme Court just said we're not going
to weigh in well I would agree on that
one you know that's the point they they
refused to weigh in on something that
was the issue I don't I don't think
even if there's you know a lot of the
things you're bringing up I do remember
vaguely that there was this stuff with
Texas and Pennsylvania but I'd have to
like think about it and read about it to
weigh in too much on that I can tell you
this however I do not believe that that
was the reason no matter what he said
that Donald Trump you know I don't think
Donald Trump was taking this big
sophisticated argum yeah I'm sorry not
the reason and I don't think that the
people who went over to the to the con
to the uh Capital that day and B in the
windows said you know it's all because
of Texas and
Pennsylvania what do you what do you
think about the uh criminal charges
against the people from January 6 I
think that we have a criminal justice
system but but en a specific example
Enrique tario was not there Enrique Taro
was not in DC but the what the jury and
there was a jury there this was the with
the proud boys he's enri was the chair
of the proud boys so the jury said based
on things that he had had done with
groups of people that he had done on
Facebook Etc a jury decided his
culpability do you think that a DC jury
was a jury of his peers well I think
that that's if he had wanted to argue
that he could not get a fair trial in in
Washington then the legal system is such
that he could have made that argument he
did they said no and they said no this
listen this interesting there's going to
be a Civil War in this country you're
saying there's going to be I I think it
is an absolute fact and I and I'll tell
you so you think that the law is being
weaponized against everybody having
anything to do with January 20 years oh
oh oh uh so first did you know that
there are people who were acquitted on
January 6th because uh they showed up
open sidewalks no Gates police fanned
them in and open the doors and then when
they went to court they said you're
honor here's a video of the cop
welcoming me in the cop said you're
right case dismissed did you know that
and they should be dismissed in that
case did you know that's hundreds of
them if if that is all that someone did
then they should be acquitted and there
are people who are going to uh people
I've met who are going to jail for 18
months because an hour after the Riot on
the other side of the building Trump was
speaking he finishes speaking the riot
is already happening after the riot was
cleared out there were many people who
showed up no barricades no signs and the
police opened the doors there's one
family that I met they were not party to
any violence they walked up the sidewalk
with little American flags they were
cops holding the door open they waved
walked in looked around they said they
were there for about 3 minutes Shrugged
and said no that was cool and then a few
months later the FBI came to their house
in the middle of the night or in early
hours in the morning arrested them in
front of their children brought them to
trial and when they argued we were there
an hour after all this there were no
signs there was no barricades the police
let us in they said we don't care guilty
18 months well that sounds wrong to me
and that's a lot of these people well
you know that that that is like hard to
believe it's true um well and I'm not
listen I'm not saying that the legal
system never makes mistakes either was
that a case that was Tried by a jury yes
uh so what did the jury say what was the
what was the prosecutions argument Trump
supporters are insurrectionists you go
to
jail I don't know I'd have about this
Tim I mean I I I agree I think you
should but yeah I mean I don't I don't
I'm not trying to say you're not saying
the truth but I'm saying some of these
conversations I would have to read I I
completely understand so the reason why
I said there's going to be a civil war
is I do not think you will
find 74 million people who voted for
Donald Trump are willing to accept that
a man who is not not at January 6 is
going to prison for 20 years for posting
on I believe it was getter quote don't
leave and for that they sentenced
Enrique too to 20 years in prison
they're not posting they're not sending
him for 20 years only for that what what
did he do they say that he had to do
with the entire setup and the entire
planning and the entire uh making it
happen he's not going to jail just for
saying don't leave are you have you read
the court documents I read an article
about it I have not read the court
documents so so my Point could be let's
put it this way Maybe I'm Wrong maybe
you're wrong yeah we can shake hands on
that and so the issue then becomes a man
is going to prison for 20 years Donald
Trump voters will not accept that will
Donald Trump voters need to read the
court documents as apparently you and I
do as well but uh I did I did that's my
point my point is I did read the case we
covered it quite extensively we've had
Enrique on the show uh several times so
you're saying that he's being a jury is
sending him to jail for 20 years and
you're saying it's only because he said
said don't leave I think they're sending
him to jail because he's a prominent
Trump supporter and the chair of the
proud boys but you're this this argument
would suggest that this massive
conspiracy by which everybody every jury
member is talking to every do you do you
think that if you uh were Tried by a
trial of of Trump's most Ardent
supporters they'd be fair to you they
this is why you have jury questioning
before someone is even allowed on to the
jury I would hope DC is 90 plus%
Democrat but still they have but a
democr a Democrat is different than
whether or not you think you think Joe
Biden would get a fair trial in in
Montana I think that there are I think
we are an in essence a purple nation in
our hearts and I think people are
interrogated before they're allowed to
sit on a jury and if they say things
that are clearly prejudicial then they
are not allowed to sit on that jury so
let's let's let's try this the people
who supported Donald Trump enough to go
in storm into the capital right yes uh
Trump got 74 million votes not every
single person would agree with that but
250,000 people were in DC that day to
support Donald Trump people holding that
sentiment do you think they would fairly
assess a criminal trial against say
hunter
Biden listen I I have two very close
friends who are Trump supporters but I
think that they would wish to give
someone a fair trial no matter who they
were I don't think that who who you
support politically I like to think that
there is a Center of conscience in this
country the fact that I support someone
politically doesn't mean I'm going to
sacrifice my Integrity or my adherence
to the law so where are the criminal
prosecutions for the riers in TW uh in
2017 in on January 20th does it set fire
to Vehicles torched things in the street
smashed Windows uh beat police anytime
anytime there is anyone who acts outside
the law there is a reason for them to be
held accountable so my question why
that's why lady you know Lady Justice
has a blindfold if it is fair then why
is it that the far-left extremists who
uh set fires and vandalized and
destroyed things in DC not only were
they acquitted uh I shouldn't say not
even acquitted the charges were dropped
but they were paid out a a million
dollar settlement why is it that in in
Washington DC when the far-left
destroys Burns and and vandalizes and
bangs on the doors and smashes their way
into these buildings
nothing well first first first of riding
in the street is different than no but I
mean like Capital the United States mean
when they call for the death of the vice
president with the GU but let's let's
let's compare say like uh a guy who the
Q Shaman for instance right you're
familiar with the Q Shaman he was
escorted into the building by police
they walk him around on video trying to
open doors for him and lead him to the
Senate chamber why did that guy go to
prison but the people who occupied and
disrupted Congress for say abortion
rights or for the for the Dakota access
pipeline
when they when the when the left goes
and occupies Congressional buildings by
force wa a minute wait a minute the
we're talking about individuals right
our elected our elected representatives
were afraid for their lives the building
was stormed but I'm not talking about
that but but but you are when you're
talking about the difference between the
shaman the who was led in by police I'm
saying pardon who was escorted in by
police so I'm comparing a specific
instance where a guy is brought in by
the police officers who give him a tour
open the door for him and show him where
to go he's he's surrounded by cops they
give him a guided tour on video this is
all you can watch it my question is in
that particular instance this one guy
who's like notorious is he goes to
prison or how about better example Owen
Shroyer did not enter the building Owen
Shroyer was at a permanent rally on the
capitol grounds and he went to prison
and just got out last week and what were
the what what what had he said had he
exhorted people to enter the building
and he exhorted people to violence I
think he said things like Democrats are
communists and communist Communists
should die against the law well he went
to prison for it well you know once
again Tim I'd have to read about that I
mean I don't I don't know about that
particular case but I think we can agree
that the that people should be not only
to be held accountable but to be held
fairly accountable and that the legal
system should be fair to everyone that's
what we can agree on I suppose the issue
for me is and the reason why I say there
will be a civil war is because when it
comes to a general conversation with the
public they believe lies from the
corporate press about what really
happened that day and on other days and
it results in torture solitary
confinement political persecutions and
this is all actively happening right now
you do think that some of the people who
came into the building that day were
acting violently we see that as well you
do believe that some people I believe a
lot of them and I believe they should go
to jail for for a good amount of time 20
20 years however well you know once once
again that's up to a jury and a judge
it's our legal system so the problem
then becomes at a certain point if
antifa uh the Summer of Love riots uh
firebomb the White House which they did
where's the where's the May 29th
hearings why why do we not have a May
29th Commission on the firebombing of
the White House in St John's Church
listen I I once again this is why why Li
Lady Liberty has a blindfold on this is
why prosecutor should try to be fair
obviously I get so what comes down to I
believe is that you don't know about it
and I don't mean that disrespectful I
mean don't know about the about the
which about the specific cases on
January 6th no no no the firebombing of
the White House on May 29th 2020 May
firebombing of the white no I don't
firebombing of the White House on May
29th 2020 so I assume that you're saying
it's because the corporate media did not
want me to know I mean no I honestly it
was reported widely there were photos of
smoke Rising all over DC it was a mass
Riot they were making fun of Donald
Trump theal yeah Donald Trump was forced
into a bunker the police came out and
started pushing people out but there's
been no hearings there's been no
commission St John's Church was set on
fire this is a historic American Church
where I know that church it's it said on
fire far-left extremists firebombed the
White House grounds the reason you don't
know 70 firebomb throwing Molotov
cocktails at the White House and torched
a guard poost 70 plus police officers
were injured so what happened nothing
nothing the reason you don't know about
it is because the media doesn't make a
big deal about it I disagree I disagree
I think it's because I with all with all
du fact I don't think you read the news
the way Trump supporters and we do I'm
not saying we as I mean there well those
two things are not mutual exclusive I
think that the average lims and so forth
because I do read the news and I do
watch and I am think of myself as
informed and I'm not I'll look trust me
I'll look I think what happens is the
average liberal is getting their news
and information from pundits not from
news sources well I think that's what's
wrong with our with our news media today
it's more people's opinions than it is
uh accurate reporting so for uh we we're
being we get smeared all the time as um
we we have this one agency trying to
smear us as fake news despite the fact
we use newsguard which is a
certification agency which G speaks
highly of the New York Times and all the
corporate press all the sources we use
are always certified as credible but
they attack us
because in terms of punditry if you
watch Chris Matthews or Rachel mattow
they are lying to you John Oliver is one
of the most deceptive manipulative
people Jimmy Kimmel is is I I view him
as malicious evil he wished uh uh death
upon his own friend live on television
with a Despicable man and then if you
watch Fox News it's like fairly bad but
not that bad you gota you definitely got
to do your own
reading but we should read super chats I
know when it com I'm just ranting when
it comes to a lot of the people that you
were mentioning uh you know on MSNBC and
CNN what I experience which is really
chilling is just complete
invisibilization eraser you know when I
was first when I first announced that I
was running for president I heard a
woman say on CNN she was obviously very
mythed that I was running and she said I
think we should just ignore her we
should just pretend that she's not
running and I thought well good luck and
that's exactly what they did that's
their playbook yeah absolutely and like
you said at 133% this week on Quinnipiac
which which is really amazing
considering the fact that I do not get
that exposure on those channels let's
let's just pretend she's not there I'll
go a little bit long to read super chats
because that's my fault and I there
there are some very nice things people
are saying to you and some good
questions Ali L says maranne I've been
blessed by your work for 15 plus years
and I appreciate you please consider
reading the early church fathers and
their writings pertaining to Jesus
Christ God bless you and Merry Christmas
to the whole timcast crew cheers very so
they're they're nice right you know uh
positive people
yes the sigp says with all due respect
as soon as they show her the JFK photo
she is going to fold to the will of the
party acknowledging the issue is not
enough Jesus what which JFK photos are
we just a plain old picture of JFK so
the the the the joke is the reason why
we don't get change is take any
presidential candidate who says good
things see the moment they sit down in
the office a guy from the CIA sits down
and says just wanted to leave this with
you and they slide a picture at JFK the
implication is yeah I understand do as
your I would like to say I would like to
think I would get on television
immediately on live television let the
people and say I am
uh I guess I would say that I'm
resigning right now but I want you to
know what's going on in your country I
appreciate that gnarly Marley says The
Grapes of Wrath Tom Sawyer and tequilla
mockberg were banned by leftists not the
right no that's not true I know I know
Tom soyer was banned by leftists that's
oh the Tom Sawyer issue is different and
it should not have been banned but
Grapes of Wrath and Kill a Mocking Bird
not I think the issue is uh there's a
difference between not in the curriculum
and banning the book outright
and a lot of what the argument is is
around
curriculum how can you say that The
Grapes of Wrath should not be in a
curriculum I'm not saying that it's one
of the great works of American
literature of world literature maybe age
appropriate or something like so the
issue is the idea The Grapes of Wrath
anybody saying Grapes of rra should not
be read by anyone for any reason is
chilling to me I I I I I don't disagree
I I'm just pointing out that a lot of
what conservatives are saying is don't
put this in curriculum leave it in the
librarian why why if a I'm not talking
about grap of w I'm not talking about
Grapes of Wrath I'm saying a lot of the
books that even like we have say
shouldn't be in the schools a lot of
conservatives are like no no no no just
it shouldn't be required reading so
we're not talking about gpes of Wrath or
k Mockingbird I'm saying that a lot of
the books that have been brought up by
the right that they say should be
removed they're not arguing for an
outright ban but like name name a book
it's one thing to talk about whether
kids you know stuff about sex in the
seventh grade but that's that's what it
is so okay well that's very some of it
is like different if this one should be
age appropriate then it should not be
available to children in the library it
can be presented in sex ad with parental
permission or whatever so it's not about
a ban it's about how they present it but
these I was reading about this woman who
comes up with this list about about what
books should be banned and she's admits
that she hardly ever read a book in her
life and anything that has any any
implication of sexual feelings to her is
pornographic this is about this woman
this is uh I think telling a a
literature teacher what they can teach
is awful Let's uh Missy kin says how
hard will marann fight back when the DNC
doesn't allow her on the ballot Bernie
didn't fight back at all okay well right
now we're we've got I've been posting
about it we've got Florida we've got
Tennessee we've got Massachusetts we've
got North Carolina the issue is how do
you fight back are you going to fight
back with a lawsuit well you talk to a
lawyer and you say well what would uh
what would be uh the cost of going after
this on the issue let's say of Florida
where the DN the Republic the Democratic
party of Florida basically said to the
State of Florida to the Secretary of
State Joe ballot Joe Biden is the only
person that we're going to have on the
ballot which is so wrong I'm an FEC
filed registered candidate I've been out
there I've been campaigning I've been
covered by by the news but that right
there is an estimated
$75,000 just for that one case in
Florida so as a as a candidate you say
where do I spend campaign funds it costs
tens of thousands of dollars ultimately
hundreds of thousands of dollars just to
get on these ballots plus uh $10,000 for
the voter files in every in every state
so are you going to spend $75,000
fighting Florida and then you begin to
see what has happened which is oh this
is not just Florida this is they're
doing it in Tennessee they're doing it
in North Carolina this week they were
doing it in Massachusetts so I'm sort of
holding powder dry because the bigger
problem is that it's a pattern I think
the main point here that matters has to
do with the function of political
parties George Washington warned us
about them in his farewell address and
he said that they could form factions of
men who were more loyal to their party
than to their country and John Adams
said that they were a threat to
democracy so the point here is that
traditionally the political party stood
in the background let the voters decide
who the nominee would be and then the
party came in so to me candidate
suppression is a form of voter
suppression so how how how much will I
fight uh as as you know certainly as
much as I can uh spending $75,000 just
to go after a case in Florida when you
also have the the cost of everything
else and the fact that everything is so
expensive is one of the ways the system
is rigged that to me is a bigger issue
so uh aligan news I'm going to rephrase
your uh uh your statement because it's
kind of a question but I'm going to
rephrase it so it's easier to just read
out in reference to the the enri tario
in in the sentencing would you agree
with black people being sentenced to
Long prison sentences if the jury
determines that's what should
happen I I I believe in the jury system
I don't think that it's always perfect
but I believe that we listen like I said
I don't agree with the Supreme Court
decision in 20 in 200000 but that
doesn't mean I was going to burn down
the Supreme Court building so so juries
come up with their decisions some of
them are fair some of them are obviously
unfair but it's the best that we have
would would you do you think that uh do
you think like a jury of uh uh white
people from a wealthy suburb are going
to be fair to a impartial to like a
black man accused of selling drugs well
I think that's why they have this that's
why this question that's why often it is
you know there is a movement for a a
case to be tried Elsewhere for that
reason I mean that's part of the system
that one can argue that one this person
could not get get a fair trial in this
area I mean that happens all the time if
a judge were to say a fair trial would
not be possible so we're going to do it
here anyway would you find that
acceptable in terms of how our system is
supposed to work no but I've never heard
a judge say that a Jud a judge I've
never heard a judge say and by the way
I'm having a little difficulty here
because I think now it's a little too
loud and I don't know if I'm talking
weird because I'm
no uh I've never heard a judge say I
admit you couldn't get a fair trial here
but we're going ahead with the trial
anyway and I don't agree with every
judge but that's just something and what
do you think would be like let's say
that hypothetically happened and there
was someone who was who was being
charged with a crime and the judge said
they they petitioned for a change of
venue and the judge says there's there's
nowhere you can go that will free you
from the bias of this place so we're
doing it here anyway I don't think that
would be right and somebody would be
petitioning somebody I mean even in
those cases there is such a thing as
judicial Prejudice somebody would be
would be arguing that there was judicial
Prejudice and this this the case would
not stop there what if the case did stop
there and the man stop they would be the
first to say this is wrong so will you
stand up in defense of Derrick
Chauvin wow
dere for change venue and the judge said
there is no there is no venue you can go
to where you'll be free of any bias so
we do it here
anyway so is the issue wasn't there some
legitimacy to that given the fact that
everybody saw the video Everybody saw
the video so how could there be a lack
of prejudice anywhere right so are you
so the question is is about uh the
Constitution and what is fair in the
court of law and not what we want to
have happened because of our feelings I
don't think the issue is a judge says
there will be no fair trial for you my
argument is then there's no trial at all
and the man should be released because
that's a limitation of our democratic
system that's what your argument would
be absolutely okay so you and I totally
disagree on that one if a court cannot
Grant a fair trial under under the
Constitution then the court cannot
imprison a person yeah well you and I
don't agree on that one so you think you
think that uh people should be the state
should be allowed to imprison people
even without due process I think that
there that that was an overriding
circumstance of the fact that the the
judge was correct there could that that
was there were very few people in the
United States who had not seen the video
that's all the judge was saying the
judge was saying you just we're going to
do our best we're going to do our best
in the way we interrogate people to make
sure that they will be as non-prejudiced
as possible but but the judge was
admitting there's no location where it's
going to be any different do you think
it was fair that the uh other officers
involved who were not other officers who
were there but not involved in the
handling of George Floyd do you think
it's fair they went to prison I think I
think that there's a lot of
accountability uh in a person who stands
there knowing if a if if you know that
somebody is murdering someone and what
he was doing it was reason able to
assume that he would die absolutely I
think trying those uh trying those
officers makes sense what if it was for
uh an one of the officers who was
holding back the crowd I wouldn't say
holding back but standing in front of
with his arms out because I don't think
he made physical contact pushing them or
anything he's going to prison and uh his
defense was he wasn't actually looking
he didn't know what was going on and as
far as he knew what chovin was doing was
in line with the training that they were
given so if I was a jury I'd be
listening very very carefully did he did
he see what was going on or not I mean
that's what a trial is for a trial to to
prove you know if if I saw if it was
clear to me as a jury member no he saw
and he chose to do nothing but if
somebody else was holding back the uh
crowd and said that he didn't even see I
would listen very carefully and I would
listen to testimony and I would see
video and it would make obviously a huge
difference whether he knew or not we're
going to go to the members only
uncensored show I really appreciate it
so uh we'll be back in about a minute we
went a little long cuz you know I didn't
read enough but uh smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net Banks we would get to uh hit
that uh Hot 100 and that would be fun I
don't think we're going to make it but
with your support it's possible uh you
can the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast marann
do you want to shout anything out no do
I want to say shout anything out your
website uh oh yeah that my website is
Maran 2024 and I would welcome people
going there we didn't really talk about
political issues as they pertain to my
campaign tonight but if people want to
see my issues and uh please go to my
social media and go to maryan t24.com.tr
Phil that remains on Twix I'm Phil that
remains official on Instagram the band
is All That Remains you can find us on
Spotify Apple music Amazon music Pandora
YouTube you know the internet I'm Ian
crosson follow me at Ian crosson on the
internet and MaryAnn you are at Mar
Williamson on Twitter great to see you
wonderful night you too we just got
started that was hot Serge talk me out
yeah um excited for the after show uh
pleasure to have you here Maran thank
you much for coming appreciate it it's
always good to have people with uh
different viewpoints than uh the average
on show as far as as our audience is
concerned anyways guys I'm surge.com
yeah let's get to the after show we'll
see you all over at timcast.net